[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le score
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce clan
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les scores
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les scores
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce clan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le score
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette 5e édition de la nuit des
chercheurs organisée par l'université de
nantes en partenariat avec télé au luxe
l'université de nantes a tenu à
maintenir cet événement mais mendy
essentielle
il faut dire que la recherche la culture
les sciences la philosophie sont
essentiels pour appréhender le monde
dans lequel nous vivons
ce sont des disciplines qui nous
permettent de nous évader d'explorer de
nouveaux horizons et de mieux comprendre
notre vie sur terre il était donc
fondamental pour l'université de nantes
de maintenir cet événement même en
distance yale et cette année la nuit
blanche des chercheurs fait le pari de
l'inattendu puisque le thème de la
soirée c'est l'imprévu alors qui dit
nouvelle édition du nouveau format il y
aura cinq temps forts de pendant ce live
ce soir au programme d'abord dans
quelques minutes nous accueillerons
pierre-antoine gourou et angelo djia
bateau pour la conférence quand
l'imprévu s'immisce dans la recherche
alliès balzer et sophie pardo et si tout
commençait par une promenade en bord de
mer ensuite place à valentine pour
sciences de comptoir qui nous a préparé
une vidéo hilarante vous verrez enfin
deux conférences art et science
viendront clore ce live c'est un format
inédit avec l'artiste est né ce dos qui
sera en direct de corée du sud et damien
éveilla sur approche du vivant à l'ère
numérique
et puis dernière conférence avec
l'artiste mao tic et baptiste chantraine
pour la conférence algorithmes et à
rencontre du troisième type
alors sachez que ces conférences dure
environ une trentaine de minutes
et nos invités répondront à vos
questions c'est interactif donc
n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions sur le tchat
les intervenants se vante un plaisir d'y
répondre
la nuit des chercheurs c'est aussi des
ateliers en live qui débuteront dès
20h15 en direct sur la page
facebook de l'université de nantes est
plein de contenus créés spécialement
pour l'événement sont disponibles sur le
site de la nuit des chercheurs
la nuit blanche des chercheurs podcast
jeu vidéo spectacles ou encore les
inattendus en sciences en format vidéo
donc des programmes extrêmement variés
et pour tous les goûts
allez cet événement enfin dernière chose
est organisée en partenariat avec
stereolux est organisée bien évidemment
par l'université nantes
on remercie la région des pays de la
loire le fonds européen de développement
régional
et puis aussi la ville de nantes pour
leur soutien on remercie évidemment
aussi les intervenants et les
partenaires scientifiques sans qu'ils
aient bien cette nuit blanche des
chercheurs n'auraient pas lieu
il ne serait pas aussi riche alors cette
nuit blanche commence par la rencontre
entre deux chercheurs que la philosophie
a réuni là elle fait d'ailleurs de la
philosophie son métier c'est angelo java
tout il est maître de conférences en
philosophie ancienne à l'université de
nantes
et puis à ses côtés il y aura
pierre-antoine gouraud il est professeur
à l'université de nantes en médecine et
praticien hospitalier au chu de nantes
il trouve dans ses recherches
biomédicales une occasion constante de
philosopher un duo extrêmement fécond
pour lancer cette soirée et j'accueille
donc sur scène
angelo djabia tôt et pierre-antoine
coraux penser à poser tout le votre
question
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir
pierre-antoine dont soir angelo ravi
d'être avec vous sur scène alors
justement pour se plonger dans ce thème
quel imprévu ce soit angelo qu'est ce
qui se cache derrière le mot imprévus
merci géraldine imprévu l'imprévu c'est
un mot complexe j'ai envie de dire que
c'est un mot à plusieurs couches alors
déjà 110 kw à 110 qu'un type d'événement
une chose donc en titre d'événement
c'est un adjectif substantive est l'âme
prévu mais comme je le disais à
plusieurs couches il ya je commence par
la fin si on repense à l'origine latine
le verbe vis des pouvoirs
puis après un prêt au préfixe qui quand
il est composé avec des verbes et des
dérivés verbaux indique la présidente
précédente spatiale ans précédé ou
temporelles comme dans notre cas prédit
qu'al attend prédit qu'au près prédire
et après un préfixe négatif donc en
chine
donc en fait l'imprévu c'est à la
rigueur la négation de l'anticipation
d'un état de perception de connaissances
que nous exprimons par l'idée de la vue
donc finalement avec un preview nous
indiquons en avidement en type
d'événement mais au fond aussi quelque
chose qui nous caractérise nous mêmes et
qui caractérise notre rapport au monde
il ya un gros deux sens possible je
terminerais là dessus on peut dire qu'un
événement à est un imprévu parce que on
ne peut pas le prévoir il est en train
segment impossible de le prévoir donc il
est imprévisible et sinon un autre une
autre typologie qui est plus intrigante
en événements bay est un an prévus parce
que notre capacité de prévision n'est
pas suffisamment forte
donc ce sont ce sera une chose
prévisible mais que nous n'arrivons pas
à prévoir
et en ce sens si dans la mesure où ça
nous confronte aux limites de notre
connaissance notre capacité de prévision
et bien c'est un moteur du dépassement
de soi pour l'être humain
enfin l'imprévu est ce qu'on appelle la
linguistique inbox médias donc ça
pourrait signifier une bonne surprise ou
une mauvaise surprise
mais en réalité nous donnons surtout une
connotation négative ajouté j'étais
confronté à des sommes prévues à
l'habitude on le dit pour se justifiait
donc au fond ce soir ce que nous allons
faire c'est réfléchir là dessus est
peut-être répand c'est le terme
peut-être eux donc je pense pas
peut-être sans doute réhabiliter
l'imprévu pierre antoine quel écho félin
prévu dans le domaine de la médecine
alors la réponse des scientifiques à cet
imprévu
c'est presque un contre-pied on va se
réfugier dans une vérité scientifique
qui est souvent exprimé par un modèle
mathématique on va construire prolongée
des données à travers un modèle
mathématique et en allant jusqu'à
essayer de prédire ou de développer de
nouveaux modèles de prédiction est de ce
point de vue là la crise pandémique de
lakovic 19 c'est bien a bien montré que
face à l'imprévu d'une crise pandémique
mondiale
on avait besoin de trouver des éléments
de vérité dans des modèles scientifiques
et pourtant cette vérité elle est aussi
extrêmement limité c'est à dire que
cette vérité elle est aussi
intrinsèquement coincé par par ses
propres
par ses propres limites donc c'est à la
fois la chambre expertise qui exprime
tout l'art la technique des
scientifiques des médecins des
épidémiologistes qui sont revenus sur le
devant de la scène et pour être à la
hauteur de angelo ce soir j'ai cru qu'il
fallait aller chercher une citation
latine sous thorn et supra à crépy dame
on aime beaucoup le latin aussi dans le
domaine médical citation un peu
mystérieuse qui
veut dire littéralement cordonnier sutor
n'est supra à crépy dame pas plus haut
que la sandale alors dans les débats
actuels
ça nous a donné c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'ultra crépy d'un misme c'est à dire
finalement reconnaître que les vérités
scientifiques quand elles sont exposées
dans le grand public
elle relève effectivement d'un champ
d'expertisé technique et de ce point de
vue la vérité scientifique n'est pas une
opinion c'est un objet technique
scientifique qui est développée comme
tel avec ses limites
charge aux scientifiques de bien
informer la décision politique avec ses
vérités scientifiques et leurs limites
angelo merci pour toutes ces
explications ferrante angelo et ses
belles citations l'imprévu questionne
dans notre rapport au monde et c'est
vrai depuis la philosophie antique dans
le fond quelles leçons tirez justement
de cette de cette histoire de la pensée
oui donc je vous le jeu voulu choisir
pour la rencontre de ce soir deux
éléments de l'histoire de la philosophie
ancienne notamment de l'époque que l'on
appelle hellénistique qui m'est très
cher pour des questions de recherche
personnelle ou notamment les deux sens
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure émergent
de manière très intéressante dans le
sens de ce que j'ai appelé une sorte de
réhabilitation de l'imprévu que l'on
conçoit souvent comme quelque chose
d'inquiétant
la première relève du domaine de la de
la cosmologie a techniquement de la
cosmogonie et se réfère à l'école
épicurienne donc l'école des piqûres je
vais aller très vite résumé je n'avais
pas à argumenter
dans la d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose
de très mystérieux même pour les
professionnels dans le la physique de
l'école épicurienne vous pouvez le voir
dans powerpoint il y avait l'idée est
incertain certains textes que finalement
pour que un monde en nylon planètes
galaxies puissent se former en certains
endroits de l'univers eh bien il fallait
à l'imprévu c'est à dire que dans ce
coin de l'univers les atom à beaune
tombait tout droit en raison de leur
poids et donc ils ne vont jamais se
rencontrer donc il est impossible que
des nouveaux corps puisse se composait
et ce qui se passe un moment donné c'est
que de manière imprévisible donc c'est
le premier sens que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et ben lande de ces atomes dévie
un clinamen déviation de cette
trajectoire et il commence à percuter
les autres donc cela permet toute une
série de chocs qui font que en premier
petit corps se forment et après ça ça
grandit de plus en plus par ajout
d'atomes et en fin de compte on aura on
aura à la fin d'un monde
mettons une planète alors qu'est ce qui
est très intéressant on voit que là un
exemple de imprévisible d'imprévus
imprévisible donc ma première typologie
et on voit à quel point ce phénomène est
essentiel pour qu'il y a constitution
d'un monde 1 ce qui est très intéressant
dans les sources anciennes à ce propos
ça me permet de faire le pont avec le
deuxième épisode que je voulais évoqué
c'est le fait que de manière assez
mystérieuse alors il ya des hypothèses
pour expliquer la chose on pourra y
revenir au moment des questions et
réponses peut-être ya des textes qui
disent finalement epicure où les épis qu
en disons plutôt là l'école a dû
introduire cette notion pour que dans
cet univers déterminé par la nécessité d
atom l'être humain puisse être considéré
comme libre
donc on faisait un lien entre une
donnait cosmologique
et la liberté humaine ça m'amène à
l'autre épisode que je pense aujourd'hui
donc le lan prévu en 30 sec est
nécessaire pour que la réalité puisse
exister sans le sou gérait cette théorie
l'autre bon évidemment le temps dans les
étudiants doivent voir venir la chose
sans doute s'est en revanche en principe
quelque chose que l'on peut tirer de
l'éthique stoïcienne donc c'était
l'autre grande école de l'époque de
l'époque hellénistique une a une éthique
il est profondément ancrée là aussi dans
la cosmologie dans la conception de
l'univers toujours en résumant très
rapidement on peut dire que les
stoïciens considéré que lorsqu ils
s'interrogeaient sur notre place dans la
réalité dans le monde considérait que
notre constitution psychique notamment
notamment rationnelle rencontre un
interagit avec les événements extérieurs
donc beaucoup sont effectivement d un
prêt du produit nous n'avons pas les
moyens pour les prévoir donc des
événements qui nous échappent des
événements qui ne dépendent pas de nous
encore un clin d'oeil à mes étudiants et
donc dont les imprévus sont une espèce
et de cette rencontre de la rencontre
entre nous et les éléments extérieurs de
ces deux causes concomitante et bien
mais notre action 1 se définit notre
présence dans le monde et se réalise
notre contribution à l'art et à la
réalisation du destin universel 1 nous
avons besoin d'être confrontés à ce qui
nous vient du monde extérieur pour agir
pour contribuer à réaliser notre place
dans le monde notamment
alors ça ça ça nous amènera à des choses
que nous allons disputer peut-être plus
tard certains textes semblent nous
suggérait que ceux ci
finalement les imprévus désagréable donc
les entrevues négatifs comme finalement
les entends com plexe qui sont les plus
féconds pour nous faire réagir pour nous
faire comme on dira être pleinement
acteur dans le théâtre du monde
pierre-antoine la dualité entre de la
compréhension et de l'action est
particulièrement vrai dans le domaine de
la médecine
en fait il ya eu un effet en fait en
effet une tension entre savoir et
pouvoir entre comprendre et où agir
comment cette dualité se concrétise
enfin dans le domaine médical
on est toujours repris dans cette
tension entre l'immense masse de
connaissances qui est l'on transporte
avec nous dans l'activité médicale et en
particulier dans la recherche le pouvoir
de soigner et puis cette tension entre
comprendre et décider tout en sachant
que parfois on comprend bien mais qu'on
ne peut pas faire grand-chose et
qu'inversement parfois on décide sans
trop savoir et c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir à quel point nos
modèles mathématiques nos modèles de
prévision d'un modèle de guérison
s'inscrivent véritablement dans cette
dans cette tension
j'aime beaucoup cette citation de
georges box un des pères de la
statistique moderne qui dit tous les
modèles sont faux mais certains sont
utiles donc ils sont faux du point de
vue de la compréhension ultime mais ils
sont quand même utile ils peuvent nous
aider à prendre des décisions et on est
dans ce rapport qui à la fois nous
interroge sur notre capacité à interagir
avec le monde dans sa compréhension mais
aussi interagir avec le monde dans notre
capacité à décider face à l'imprévu et
dans la crise et c'est peut-être
finalement en renonçant à comprendre que
l'on peut mieux agir on parle souvent
d'hommes augmenté d'intelligence
artificielle dia on a quand même
l'impression finalement que l'homme au
dessus tout que l'ia change la donne
mais est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
dans ce monde-là gencher
calcul ou est-ce qu'on va placer
finalement l'humain oui comment dire il
y a quelque chose de 2,2 frais de qui
fait du bien dans ce que pierre-antoine
bien de dire c'est à dire le fait que
finalement même dans ce monde qui est
celui de la science qu'on veut exact
un qui l'on veut
on souhaiterait qu'il nous accompagne
vers cette forme au fond de deux hommes
augmentait réaliser davantage écho font
effectivement dans ce contexte de
partage d on partage cette conscience
des limites qui sont les nôtres comme on
dit à e oui on peut gérer bien aux deux
sens de d'imprévus que j'ai évoqué avant
nous avons le devoir moral de essayer de
nous dépasser
notamment dans le domaine des
connaissances
nous pouvons imaginer comme cette
mouvance de pensée semble le suggérer
que nous devons concrètement
physiquement repousser les limites de
l'humain et mais au fond c'est justement
notre nature limitait qui nous rend ce
que nous sommes nous sommes des êtres
humains parce que nous avons la
possibilité de connaître et des limites
dans la connaissance
donc je veux toujours j'aime beaucoup
parlé souvent de rapprochement
asymptotique c'est à dire que nous
devons disait un être humain plus
parfait augment de tête qu'on me la
plaie mais finalement à au bout d'un
moment nous arrêtons et donc nous
aboutissons finalement à une comment
dire à une condition humaine j'ai envie
de dire qu'ils que je vais décrire parce
que là finalement c'est plus le
scientifique qui a fait du l'attendons
classe et c'est un mois là bas tu parles
de 70 on est quand même dans la
trigonométrie oui voilà exactement l'âge
on à aulas bien partager les les
domaines vraiment deux expressions
latines qui exprime ce que ce que la
réflexion peut
nous apporter dans ce contexte par
rapport à ces questionnements le premier
alors c'est un imprévu un parce qu'il
n'est pas dans notre power punk mais
c'est venu à l'idée nasri voilà exerce
le thème de la soirée c'est neil admis
larry ne s'étonner de rien c'était la
traduction latine de l'expression
grecque mais des nattes en médecine qui
signifie vivre dans le monde en
acceptant l'imprévu donc à l'accepter
entre autres nôtre en capacité foncière
de le gérer et ne pas s'étonner ne pas
s'étonner ou encore saas apparemment
c'était pythagore qu'il avait lancé les
solutions qu'il aurait prennent beaucoup
des le la fondation de l'école
parrainons qui disait que quand le la
conduite de vie est réalisé selon nature
sonné à des sky
atau bastos donc on s en est besoin et
sans étonnement et bien comment dire à
ceux à cette absence d'étonnement ce sa
compagne une forme d' absence de
mécontentement vis-à-vis des événements
parce que justement nous reconnaissons
notre nature limitait même si doucement
nous essayons de faire tout le possible
pour la dépasser pour l'interroger
ce qui nous ramène alors à la à quelque
chose qui n'est pas en prévu parce qu'on
l'avait prévu dans notre power pointe
c'est-à-dire cette idée que j'ai déjà
anticipé terrasse paiera à d'astra
augusto langoustes c'est à dire pas
redescendre terrasse père est ardu
jusqu'aux étoiles ça résume un peu ce
que on est en train de dire c'est à dire
bah comme le cadre de la médecine
notamment il ya un effort constant pour
modéliser pour toucher à une forme de
vérité
l'éthique
la réflexion philosophique dans le
domaine de l'anthropologie philosophique
de la morale je prenais l'exemple de
destitution pouces effectivement à nous
confronter avec l'inconnu et c'est par
ces démarches qui sont certes difficiles
parce que s'il se fonde sur la
conscience de notre finitude que nous
arrivons aux étoiles là nous habite tous
que nous aboutissons à une forme de
réalisation j'insiste dans dans des
limites
donc c'est comme ça que j'interpréterai
aujourd'hui cette mouvance vers un
instrument augmenter ce n'est qu'une
forme de d'expression de ce désir entre
enseignement iman de dépassement mais
qui règne en toujours dans ses limites
qui sont notre force
merci pour ces belles citations et
parfois brisées merci rapidement avant
de poser aux questions justement des
spectateurs qui nous regardent pierre
antoine est ce que ça fait peur ce monde
là alors peut-être avant de répondre à
votre question est peut-être la peur que
suscite des techniques moi je trouve
très beau dans ce que dit angelo où
finalement cet imprévu qui montre qu'on
ne comprend pas qui montrent qu'on
n'arrive pas bien à aj voix décidée
parce qu'on n'a pas les outils de
prédiction ou pas encore ou qu'il faut
les développer
finalement cet imprévu qui nous sort de
notre zone de confort c'est le substrat
même du progrès et donc on a peut-être
justement cet imprévu qui montrent nos
limites
en fait est une occasion de progrès pour
chacun alors évidemment ça questionne
notre interaction avec les techniques
nos moyens et quand on parle d'hommes
augmenté
effectivement la technique fait toujours
peur parce qu elle nous emmène un peu au
delà de manière parfois un peu mécanique
et donc on a cette question de
l'intelligence artificielle du rôle des
données de comment ces données sont
mobilisés pour répondre à une situation
et dans deux projets compter qu'ils ont
vraiment mobiliser notre campus
et puis l'écosystème du territoire
nantais le projet argos qui nous a
permis
qui nous a exigé de mettre en place un
outil pour mieux comprendre comment a
évolué la pandémie chez nous localement
en cumulant les données qui sont celles
du chu sur celle du samu et des urgences
de sos médecins des laboratoires des
laboratoires privés
eh bien on a mis en place de nouveaux
outils pour mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe et puis ça a été le cas aussi dans
le projet macaire là encore une
formidable mobilisation du chu nantes de
la communauté des chercheurs des
meilleurs des entrepreneurs de la
communauté de l'antenne pour concevoir
en trois semaines seulement un
dispositif médical avec toute la
documentation possible sans transiger
avec les règles parce que ce qui prime
c'est la sécurité des soignants la
sécurité des patients eh bien on a été
les premiers et les seuls au monde à
faire respirer un être humain avec une
machine conçue dans dans l'urgence dans
l'exigence de la crise et ça c'est
possible justement parce que très tôt on
voit dans le numérique des nouvelles
opportunités des choses qu'on n'avait
pas la possibilité de faire avant tout à
l'heure damien eveillard de montrera
comment le numérique change notre
perception du vivant c'est fondamental
c'est très important pour les
biologistes et pour les médecins de
comprendre la complexité du vivant qu'il
soit normal ou pathologique et pour nous
c'est vraiment un enjeu de saisissement
de la technique et là encore je crois
qu'il faut renverser
nos craintes ou prendre nos craintes
comme une opportunité
un imprévu qui nous appellent à
progresser et on a coutume de dire
qu'effectivement quand on parle
d'intelligence artificielle de big data
bien non l'homme ne va pas être
remplacée par une intelligence
artificielle
en revanche l'homme qui n'interagissent
est pas avec cette intelligence
artificielle et bien il va être périmés
un peu celui là l'intelligence
artificielle
on va avoir une nouvelle génération qui
elle est appelée à interagir avec avec
ces nouveaux outils techniques sans en
avoir peur ou sans d adopter comme des
fans mais au contraire à entrer en
interaction et a intégré dans son
existence
ces nouveaux outils avec lesquels il
interagit avec lesquels ils existent
merci à tous les deux on va passer
maintenant si vous voulez bien au coin
salon pour répondre aux questions et
bien des internautes
venez steve et moi asseyez-vous alors il
nous reste un peu moins 10 minutes
pourquoi avons-nous tendance à
considérer l'imprévu comme négatif c je
commence ici il est alors vous avez
justement parlé de sa honda ni loi oui
c'est une très belle question je pense
que
la raison c'est que l'imprévu nous sort
de notre zone de confort est évidemment
l'imprévu l'imprévisible ou l'imprévu
prévisible nous confronte à nos limites
et donc effectivement je trouve que pour
l'être humain c'est c'est sans doute
difficile de reconnaître sa nature
limitait je pense que c'est ça la raison
en revanche il peut ya voir ça fait
partie de la du caractère malléable de
la nature humaine est humaine nous
pouvons dans notre esprit faire ce
changement de paradigme à nous dire ce
que justement des philosophes notamment
dans l'antiquité
on dit merci merci au monde de me
confronter constamment avec quelque
chose que je n'entendais pas parce que
voilà un exercice pour pour ma mon
progrès vous voilà un exercice pour
monde est un monde dépassement de moi la
sagesse serait ce de reconnaître ses
limites afin de ne pas nuire à sa propre
intelligence
je crois que là on a un point commun
avec angelo ou le chercheur en sciences
biomédicales que je suis finalement plus
on progresse dans la carrière plus on a
un grand nombre de publications plus on
échange avec les collègues du monde
entier
plus on a l'impression de ne pas savoir
grand chose
ou peut-être finalement comme le dit
cette question de mieux connaître
l'immensité des limites de nos savoirs
avec cette force des vérités
scientifiques qu'elle soit philosophique
ou ou biomédicale mais c'est peut-être
justement aux marges de nos savoirs que
la sagesse fenêtre où l'intérêt
peut-être l'excitation l'étonnement
scientifique est véritablement présent
on n'arrive toujours pas à prévoir la
météo comment le voyez-vous jeu j'adore
cette question donc je vais bien merci
la personne qui l'a posée disons je
pourrais dire oui effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui vous confronte avec
les
limites de notre connaissance notamment
dans la météorologie tout ce qu'on veut
pas ça ce serait là la réponse sage
ils ont confortable et moi en fait je
trouve que dans le fait qu'on ne puisse
cadrer voire souvent les événements
météorologiques il y a une c'est une
manière très féconde de constater à quel
point le monde qui nous entoure
justement ou dépasse quel point la la
complexité de la nature un complexité
est un mot qui est souvent revenu dans
nos discussions préparatoires
on n'a pas eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
mais c'est peut-être la bonne occasion
oui très bien on voudrait on voudrait
certes en tant qu'être humain savoir si
demain il neige ou pas mais la nature
nous dépasse c'est pareil aussi une
bonne leçon de modestie
on a vu aujourd'hui prévu la neige elle
est arrivée là mis un petit peu de temps
et je crois que si on regarde aussi les
prédictions météo ont énormément
progressé et elles ont progressé pas
simplement fiabilité mais en mesure de
leurs propres incertitudes et ça je
pense que c'est une dimension qu'on ne
laquelle on n'insiste pas assez
en fait nos prédictions elle elle
progresse aussi dans l'eure dans leur
capacité à dire quel est leur degré de
précision il s'agit pas simplement de
prédire mais de prédire avec quel
pourcentage de certitudes et ça c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu changé
c'est vrai dans le domaine de la météo
c'est vrai dans beaucoup d'autres
beaucoup d'autres domaines
merci quels sont les genres d'imprévus
prévisible dans la recherche et que
peut-on ou doit-on anticipées je pense
que c'est une question plus 10 pour 1
pierre antoine
alors je sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
imprévu qu'on peut prédire si j'ai bien
écouté angelo par nature un imprévu
n'est pas n'est pas prévisible
en revanche on peut avoir des conditions
d'application d'un modèle ou des
conditions d'un phénomène auquel ce qui
apparaît
qui sont nouvelles ou qui sont pas
attendus et je crois que ça c'est une
forme c'est peut-être de réfléchir aussi
la robustesse de nos maux d'alès qui
sont extrêmement dépendants des
hypothèses dans les prédictions de
l'ampleur de la pandémie
je crois que les scientifiques ont fait
les épidémiologistes qu'on essayait de
faire un travail le plus honnête
possible non seulement donné les
prédictions et ont aussi montré à quel
point par exemple le fameux airs zéro le
taux de réplication moyen du virus dans
une population s'ils changent d'un petit
chouya ça modifie beaucoup la prédiction
et ça je pense que c'est déjà un signe
d'une grande maturité une responsabilité
de scientifiques au service de la
décision politique que de montrer
comment ces imprévus ou que le
prévisible de la science est déterminée
par des hypothèses vouliez acheter
quelque chose en dit long oui
effectivement
comment dire le par rapport à ce que je
disais je disais aussi tout à l'heure
hallyday serait qu' il y aurait un
double mouvement dans la science c'est à
dire que la science a devrait être en
mesure de définir de pouvoir distinguer
alors après c'est quelque chose qui a
concerné l'épistémologie tout au long de
sa son histoire mais définir quels sont
effectivement les choses que l'homme ne
s'est pas encore fait les choses qu'on
ne peut pas foncièrement connaître
travailler sur la première mais pareil
même cette distinction est extrêmement
fragile
qu'en est-il de l'avancé quantique et
des prédictions plus exactes de l'avenir
qui en découlent
n'y at il pas un risque de dérive du
pouvoir alors je veux d'abord répondu
bien sûr le les capacités de calcul les
ordinateurs quantiques nous offre des
capacités à faire encore encore plus de
calcul que ce que nous pouvons faire
aujourd'hui donc là on rendez-vous
peut-être dans dix ans pour voir comment
on aura pu se saisir de ces nouvelles
opportunités de calcul on est déjà en
train d'envisager certaines choses voilà
ça a été une partie de ma journée
aujourd'hui et je voudrais répondre sur
le politique ce que ce soit ça me semble
une question particulièrement importante
pour moi le risque vis-à-vis du
politique
il est double et je crois
malheureusement qu'on l'a très bien vu
dans deux mouvements dans la crise qui
est encore la nôtre au début de la crise
finalement le politique fait trop
confiance aux scientifiques ou si cette
confiance à des mesures et par les
hypothèses du modèle on l'a dit et
finalement il délègue son autorité
politique à des prédictions
mathématiques mais les prédictions
mathématiques sont relativement muette
sur le sens de la décision politique au
mieux et avec le plus de netteté
possible et en soulignant toutes les
limites des prédictions le rôle du
scientifique
encore une fois la communauté a été très
mobilisés dans toute la crise va dire
ben voilà ce qu'on peut dire mais ces
modèles finalement sont assez muet sur
les conséquences économiques
on a un modèle sanitaire et ça ça relève
du champ de la décision politique est
aujourd'hui on a peut-être dans le
mouvement inverse
on a aujourd'hui un niveau qui est assez
élevé une occupation des hôpitaux que
que l'on connaît et peut-être une
décision politique qui par effet de
contre-pied ou deux contres balancier et
peut-être davantage sourde aux
informations que prodigue ses modèles
scientifiques
je voudrais juste rebondir sur le fait
je trouvais la question très
intéressante parce qu'elle renvoie à
quelque chose que j'avais évoqué
peut-être rapidement
la question à mon avis montre à quel
point on associe encore aujourd'hui dans
notre sentir landes détermination et
l'existence d'un prévu à une forme de
liberté
le fait qu'on associe la le fait de
détenir des moyens de prévoir des choses
à au fonds abus de pouvoir c'est ce qui
était impliqué on voit à quel point
effectivement il y à des ré ton mec qui
touche effectivement au domaine de la
liberté comme si au fond oui on cherche
à connaître mais dans le fait qu'il n'y
ait personne connaisse vraiment où il ya
quelque chose de rassurant par rapport
aux rapports de pouvoir entre les êtres
humains il reste trois minutes merci
parce que vous êtes très nombreux vous
êtes plus de 400 à vous connecter et à
poser les questions merci beaucoup
la démarche scientifique est elle la
seule garante pour comprendre l'imprévu
là encore ça suspect rends toi je pense
que c'est sert alors il faut
certainement entendre la démarche
scientifique au sens le plus large
possible et pas simplement les modèles
épidémiologiques qui répondent à une
crise sanitaire
la démarche scientifique quant à des
philosophies quand elle est historique
et extrêmement informative aussi pour
comprendre et faire face à l'imprévu
dans le projet macaire donc cette
conception d'un respirateur artificiel
par une équipe qui très majoritairement
dans un n'a pas de connaissances a
priori dans les dispositifs médicaux
destinés à la ventilation mécanique est
bien la culture l'histoire sont en fait
extrêmement déterminant dans les options
que l'on va prendre avec parfois
d'explorer en parallèle plusieurs pistes
peut-être même contradictoire pour
pouvoir développer une solution
rapidement dernière question n'est ce
pas une preuve de prudence pour un
scientifique que dit magique toutes les
hypothèses afin d'en déduire des
techniques permettant de surpasser la
fortune alors je le serai angelo
conclure mais j'aime beaucoup cette
question merci infiniment
un scientifique un scientifique prudent
on pourrait un bon scientifique il vit
en permanence dans le doute
c'est à dire que si vous n'arrêtez pas
si mes étudiants de mar est pas aussi je
n'arrête pas mes étudiants nous ne
publierons jamais nous prendrons jamais
de décision on va continuer à faire des
calculs
on va continuer à s'interroger si on
faisait les choses un peu différemment
et c'est assez intéressant et c'est donc
effectivement il ya cette idée que on va
essayer toutes les hypothèses peut-être
il n'y a pas du tout de proportionnalité
entre la productivité de connaissances
et la quantité d'efforts qui va être qui
va être déployé dans tel ou tel dans tel
ou tel aspect donc oui le plus
d'hypothèses possible mais à un moment
il faut comprendre et peut-être agir en
moins d'une minute
je ne peux qu'être d'accord avec terrain
antoine effectivement c'est un principe
de prudence et en devoirs pour le
scientifique dans le sens large très
beau car antoine a évoqué que de
considérer les donnaient que d'émettre
des hypothèses et
après deux conclure avec ce que
l'honneur de faire le maximum avec ce
qu'on a réussi à tirer de la réflexion
et de l'étude
merci à tous les deux merci pierre
anthony fauci
angelo gelato merci à tous les deux on
va accueillir maintenant agnès walser et
sophie pardo avec leur conférence
intitulée et si tout commençait par une
promenade en bord de mer
[Musique]
l'imprévu est partout tout le temps y
compris dans des endroits que l'on
n'imaginerait pas comme en vacances par
exemple sur une plage les marées les
tempêtes dévoilent leurs mystères et
leur imaginaire aux archéologues
sous-marins
ces événements imprévisibles donne lieu
à de belles découvertes que vont nous
dévoiler ce soir à nice balzer et sophie
pardo agnès valzer et professeur de
géographie de la mer et du littoral à
l'université de nantes et sophie pardo
est maître de conférences en
microéconomie de l'incertain à
l'université également de nantes
prenez vos billets pour embarquer et
bien pour un voyage imprévu dans le
temps à travers le littoral j'accueille
tout de suite sur scène agnès balsa et
sophie pardon
[Musique]
bonsoir à tout les deux bonsoir sophie
bonsoir agnès et je vous laisse et bien
avec votre public en virtuel pour 30
minutes de conférence
à tout à l'heure pour les questions
penser à poser toutes vos questions
elle y répondrons tout à l'heure merci
merci jamais une vigne bonsoir à tous
agnès est prête pour une balade au bord
de la mer à allez c'est parti
balade au bord de la mer moi ça va très
très bien en fait il faut que je t'avoue
quelque chose en fait c'est ma façon de
travailler c'est ça c'est me balader au
bord de la mer et c'est parce que plus
je regarde la mer et plus je regarde
sous l'eau plus je regarde loin dans le
temps loin dans le temps mais c'est quoi
loin dans le temps pour toi c'est dix
ans décision publique
cinquante ans un bon cycle économique
nan nan nan plus que ça aux baies
beaucoup angoissent déjà j'ai perdu la
mémoire et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que plus se regarde loin sous
l'eau plus tu peux regarder à des
milliers d'années dans le temps en
arrière
et justement ben là je vais vous
raconter une petite histoire qui nous
est arrivé c'était j'étais d'abord
j'avais fait d une connaissance
incroyable c'était avec monsieur serge
cassen un archéologue et moi je suis
chez hologue marin donc c'était
quelqu'un d'autre qui a regardé les
choses de façon différente
est ce que c'est le monsieur qu'on voit
sur à la normale 800 à un jeune touriste
écossaise et qui a dans les mains
justement 2h en jadéite c'est à dire en
fait ce sont des âges funéraire qui
appartenait aux hommes néolithique
donc il ya de cela sept mille ans et ce
monsieur écossais en marchant sur la
plage eh bien il s'est un petit peu de
trancher le pied et il s'est dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ces cailloux
époque il a sorti ses 2 à change a dit
il a compris qu'il avait à faire quelque
chose d'étonnant
et c'est monsieur serge cassen entre
autres cas validés et reconnus ch et là
où ch était intéressante et c'est
justement tout s'est tu
cette image que vous voyez c'est quand
s'est aperçue qu'elle matérialise l
emplacement de menhirs donc de stèles
érigées et donc ses menhirs
on est là ici sur la presqu'île de
quiberon alors tout le monde connaît les
menhirs les grands alignement de venir
sur des kilomètres quand on est à carnac
évidemment mais à saint pierre de
quiberon on connaissait deux trois
quatre petits menhir l'alignement du
moulin qu'on peut voir un peu dans les
lotissements et en fait il était
probable qu'il y avait des grands
alignement avant et du coup pour
remonter dans le temps pour ces trouver
la suite de ces alignements on est allé
voir sous l'eau et donc sous l'eau
qu'est ce qu'on a vu on a vu ce que vous
voyez qui est ressemble plein de petits
points blancs en fait chacun de ces
petits points blancs correspondent à des
menhirs sous l'eau et c'est là où
c'était extrêmement intéressant c'est
que donc cette double approche
archéologiques et puis géologie nous
montrer qu'on avait des alignements sur
plus de 900 m de menhirs marins de
manière sous l'eau et ça veut dire pour
le niveau marin qu'il était plus haut ou
plus bas
je laisse les internautes répondre et
donc en fait il était plus bas dans gros
7 mètres et donc ça nous donnait comme
ça une vision sur le passé en regardant
ce littoral qui avait bougé qui avait
évolué donc tu es en train de dire que
plus la marée découvre plus on remonte
dans le temps on va loin dans le temps
et qu'on retrouve des traces en fait de
civilisation finalement qui datent de
milliers d'années et si on pouvait
remonter encore au gré du très très très
très grandes marées peut-être que tu
remonterait encore d'un exactement et
même une grande marée de grand goâve
tu peux te balader tu fais une balade du
néolithique si tu veux quasiment c'est
avec grand plaisir
bah écoute c'est très intéressant
maintenant si on se projette dans le
futur est ce que on peut faire la même
chose le même exercice pour imaginer que
dans le futur la mer va remonter
malheureusement un peu plus sur le
littoral c'est ce qui commence à se
passer et moi ce qui m'intéresse quand
je me balade sur littoral
c'est de regarder finalement des
événements qui sont un peu moins un peu
moins attirant mais qui sont quand même
important que sont les tempêtes il est
submersion et tout à l'heure je te
parlais de mémoire courte parce que
quand on regarde les décisions qui sont
prises et puis le comportement des
agents vis-à-vis dossiers de ces risques
là on s'aperçoit qu'on a quand même la
mémoire courte
voilà par exemple on a recensé les
événements de deux tempêtes et de
submersion marine qui ont eu lieu sur la
zone de la rochelle donc tu vois sur un
ton beaucoup moins l'oncle tiens
puisqu'on commence dans les années à
1500 et quelques on s'aperçoit que le
temps ait pas linéaire puisque vous avez
des épisodes qui vont se succéder et qui
s'intensifie en termes de nombre en
particulier donc il s'accélère au début
du 20e siècle et donc dans cette dans
cette phase là dans ce secteur là c'est
là où a lieu grimm tiens donc c'est vrai
que le xynthia a été une tempête
particulièrement intense avec énormément
de dégâts et de décès malheureusement et
pour autant il y avait déjà eu des
phénomènes qu'on avait peut-être un peu
oublié parce qu'ils étaient un peu moins
intense et puis parce qu'il remontait un
certain nombre d'années et si on regarde
sur le secteur de la baie de l'aiguillon
donc c'est l'autre tableau on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya eu quand même 25 épisodes de
submersion qui sont restés quand même
dans la mémoire depuis le xviiie siècle
est en fait tu vois c'est ça c'est parce
que la mémoire de l'homme et des petites
quand on oublie un peu ses tempêtes mais
là ce que tu me montres
c'est peut-être sur un menhir grave et
j'aurais pu retrouver les mêmes séries
tempête qu'avait vécu à ce moment là nos
hommes du néolithique
mais c'était en fait c'est ça c'est ces
cycles de tempêtes ces grands cycles
naturels qui reviennent et qui font
qu'on revit un peu les mêmes histoires
ou en tout cas les mêmes événements avec
un enchaînement qui peut différer
peut-être un petit peu mais voilà on a
cette mémoire des cycles et elle est
importante
peut-être si tu me passes la diapo
d'après voilà c'était justement cette
mémoire des sigles et c'est juste pour
se remettre dans la nature puisqu'on est
dans notre environnement et celle de
l'environnement il a des grands sites
des moyens s'il des petits sites et
quand même les cycles de la nature ils
sont beaucoup plus importants que les
cycles de l'homme c'est pour ça qu'on a
tendance à ne pas être calé exactement
et la hongrie en vain dans
calage en ce moment entre les
environnements et nous et là c'est la
diapo que vous voyez en ce moment c'est
juste pour montrer qu'en fait la limite
continent océans elle est
perpétuellement en mouvement donc ça
monte ça descend au gré des glaciations
interglas ciation et qu'en fait le
paysage que nous on voit émerger il sera
peut être submergé dans pas très
longtemps ou au contraire il était
complètement dégagé il ya quelques
milliers d'années je te montre ça parce
que sur la diapo suivante tu vas voir
ces grands cycles et ça explique
pourquoi l'homme évidemment il a du mal
à réfléchir à long terme parce que lui
il a une vie qui est courte et là c'est
les grands cycles c'est juste pour vous
montrer à quoi ça ressemblait par
exemple la les entrées de la manche va
vous montez sur la entre l'angleterre à
gauche et la france
à droite anvers est là tout ce que vous
voyez c'est en bleu sous l'eau
maintenant mais en fait vous passez le
plateau continental et pouf une grande
marche et vous arrivez dans les abysses
sauf que si je prends par exemple
vingt mille ans et vingt mille ans comme
ça tu vois à peu près ce que ça donne
peu près juste parce que en été ou
dernier maximum glaciaire et là le
niveau marin
comme je disais fluctuant du coup ils
étaient 120 mètres plus bas
et l'image que tu vois à droite c'est la
terrasse de mériadeck pouvait aller
boire un café si tu voulais terrasse on
était donc sur le bord de la pente
continental juste avant d'aller sur
l'océan et tu le voyais presque à pied
sec pas tout à fait j'exagère un peu
mais en tout cas on ne pouvait voilà le
paysage il était que la france et
l'angleterre était exactement sur la
même continuité et donc on a une
impression comme ça qu'on niveau marin
au monde que c'est quelque chose de très
linéaire très très grand et ainsi de
suite
et si je te montre la diapo d'après je
m'aperçois que quand je suis au niveau
du littoral
et là vous revoyez une image où on voit
le
le golfe du morbihan en fait la remontée
du niveau marin elle est passée
lignières que ça parce que c'est
tellement compliqué ce littoral s'est
découpé c'est pas des coupes et ainsi de
suite
et là on voit simplement sur les dix
mille dernières années que niveau marin
il est remonté très très vite et puis
tout d'un coup ça s'est ralenti et temps
en temps pour la mer aller un peu plus
loin parce qu'on avait quelques une de
tes tempête qui se suivent comme tu
viens de nous montrer et l'ol envahi
tout d'un coup et bien le golfe du
morbihan qui est quelque chose comme une
espèce de grande cuvette et c'est là que
les meunières marrane par exemple tout
d'un coup les pauvres hommes du
néolithique leur mire les ont vus faire
l'ongle ou d'être sous l'eau enfin
peut-être pas tout à fait mais en tout
cas voilà ça alors à saâles et ça a
changé leur littoral à eux aussi les
langues déjà vécu donc il faut regarder
en arrière c'est très important
ouais mais nous aussi on regarde en
arrière et c'est très important pour les
tempêtes aussi et là par exemple sur
cette carte on voit le niveau d'eau donc
les zones qui ont été inondées par la
tempête xynthia donc en onze ans
maintenant
c'était au mois deux mois dès fin
février ou en 2006 et donc on voit le
bleu là c'est toute la mère qui a été
qui a recouvert les terres alors c'est
un c'est un événement qui était prévu
parce que ça a été une conjonction de
deux phénomènes des vitesses de vent
importante de conjuguer avec une tempête
quand l'aiguillé avec payants seront
coefficient 2 et j'avais envie de te
montrer
à quel point ce qui a fait vraiment
l'imprévu puisque sur la courbe là on
voit le rythme des marées en fait avec
la comparaison entre ce qui a été
observé
c'est le plus foncé les plus les pics
les plus haut on va dire et puis ce qui
a été prévu
oui on voit qu'au plus fort de la
tempête et bien la hauteur d'eau elle
était vraiment imprévue donc malgré les
modèles qui sont qui sont là pour
essayer finalement d'anticiper un petit
peu ces phénomènes l'un de bien les
comprendre
la hauteur d'eau qui a été qui a été
celle de xynthia était particulièrement
imprévisibles et donc ça la classe cette
tempête parce et ses hauteurs d'eau
extrêmement importante sa violence dans
des épisodes qu'on appelle deux avec un
retour sans tonight à dire en gros ça
revient tous les cent ans
et ça c'est un point important qui fait
que finalement la mémoire humaine elle
elle va un petit peu effacé ces épisodes
là ils sont très intenses mais certaines
personnes se dit bon ben voilà c'est
arrivé ça reviendra donc cela reviendra
pas ouais c'est donc à l'échelle d'une
vie humaine c'est quelque chose qui est
difficilement appréhendables alors
effectivement quand un tel épisode ce
produit là ça la rend beaucoup plus
réaliste vraisemblable et on va essayer
de s'en prémunir
alors je te disais que c'est important
de revenir sur le passé parce que les
hommes ils ont fait le mouvement inverse
c'est à dire que le mouvement qui nous a
montré le niveau de la mer et là sur ses
cartes on voit finalement l'action de
l'homme donc je t'emmène dans le temps
dans 676 alors c'est hier pour toi une
carte donc de sainte colombe qui montre
la baie de l'aiguillon et la
faute-sur-mer donc le territoire qui a
été touchée de façon dramatique par la
tempête xynthia et on voit très
nettement que
la partie la grande baie elle est pas du
tout occupée il s'agit de marc est alors
démarrer qui sont humides
il ya simplement quelques petites îles
que l'on voit à fleuret par ci par là et
même la pointe de l'aiguillon elle est
beaucoup plus fine que ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
sur la carte de droite on voit le des
travaux menés par tes collègues jaloux
tg et donc ils ont cartographié les
niveaux d'eau qui ont été ceux de
xynthia qui ont recouvert la baie et on
s'aperçoit sur les rectangles rouge que
ce sont des partis qui ont été indiquées
donc il a été gagné par l'homme sur la
lune sur les marées donc ils ont asséché
c'est la construction du marais poitevin
et c'est endiguement ont commencé en
1595 avec un art été acceptée par henri
iv mais ça a continué c'est ça qui est
intéressant
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle donc ce
mouvement inverse finalement la mer
monte et l'homme et locales avec des
échelles de temps qu'ils sont
effectivement extrêmement différente de
ce que tu nous a montré et ce qui est
très surprenant est assez troublant et
qui à mon sens fait mémoire et doit être
important pour pour les décisions
futures
c'est que la mer en gros si vous
regardez les deux cartes au moment de
xynthia avec des phénomènes fin d'été
des paramètres de cette tempête
extrêmement rare qui avaient peu trop à
éviter de se retrouver de façon qu'on
commence à être est bien la mère a
repris finalement exactement le
territoire qu'elle occupe et lors du
traçage tracé de cette carte en 776 est
donc là du coup c'est là quand on voit
que si on pense en arrière c'est en
boucle en arrière si on pense boucler à
temps c'est mieux pensée boucler ça
c'est mon adage en ce moment c'est à
dire que en fait on pouvait prédire
jusqu'où elles allaient remonter la mer
au prochain épisode
donc c'est ça c'est ces travaux qui sont
importants je reste pour ce croisement
de ces recherches que l'on peut faire
tous ensemble c'est de se dire que on
est capable d'éclairer peut-être le
présent et le futur avec un peu de
chance si on arrive à faire des modèles
pour voir un peu à quel endroit les la
côte les
et les littoraux vont être plus ou moins
impactés par le niveau marin qui remonte
puisque bon là on est effectivement dans
une temporalité où le niveau marin
remonte mais là sur ce type de recherche
le croisement des disciplines
extrêmement important le croisement des
connaissances parce que un économiste
qui va faire des prévisions une analyse
coûts bénéfices ou coût efficacité de
certaines mesures n'a pas cette
connaissance historique vient cette
profondeur historique qu on peut
retrouver dans avec des historiens ou
les géographes et donc vraiment tout ce
qui concerne finalement la manière de
d'appréhender les risques de sang propos
de s'en protéger et et de d'imaginer des
solutions d'adaptation
elle mérite vraiment cette
pluridisciplinarité et je pense aussi
effectivement que c'est le rôle peut en
tout cas pour la science pour les
scientifiques de pouvoir justement
éclairé aussi les décideurs les gens qui
vont faire l'aménagement du territoire
c'est le moment justement que la science
puisse éclairer les décisions les
aménagements pour justement montrer à
quoi ça peut ressembler la balade ça je
te montre comment on fabrique une île
voilà alors mon moment préféré pour
faire une île c'est pas difficile
en fait cette image elle est
intéressante parce que on a monté avec
une collègue elsa carew qui est sur
l'île d'yeu on a monté tout un programme
odyssée yeux observatoire de la
dynamique sédimentaire de l'île d'yeu et
en fait c'était rigolo parce qu'au
départ pour
monter ce projet on a déposé une
question qui était très simple comment
on fait une île est ce que tu sais
comment on fait une île
alors on prend beaucoup de sable
cherchons bien des cailloux un peu comme
non non c'est pas ça je sais je sais que
c est en fait c'était drôle parce que
ils pensaient qu'une il s'était alors
ils vont éventuellement pour peut-être
des enfants où certains adultes
c'était un truc envoie un morceau un peu
peut-être en créer par on sait pas
quelle magie au fond et pour beaucoup de
gens c'était un volcan forcément une île
c'était un volcan et
il n'y avait pas du tout cette
conscience de ce fameux niveau marin qui
bouge qui monte qui descend suivant des
étangs et donc simplement l'île d'yeu
c'était un morceau du continent comme
comme quiberon comme même des lille
comme beaucoup d'îles comme ça et en
fait elles se sont retrouvées on a
fabriqué des îles
parce que le niveau marin il est monté
c'est les courbes que je vous montrais
tout à l'heure et donc cette île d'yeu
qui est relié comme même au continent
par le pont d'yeu qui a longtemps été
reliés par le plomb dieu au continent en
fait elle s'est faite se transformer en
il
je dirais un peu comme l'angleterre
puisque c'est vrai aussi pour
l'angleterre et l'irlande comme je les
montre et en gros vais rentrer à des
7000 5,8 milan d'accord donc tu en train
de nous de montrer que peut-être que la
presqu'île de quiberon dans 3000 5000
ans pourrait devenir une île célibat
c'est très bien c'est à dire que voilà
le niveau marin qui m'ont tant le voilà
qui monte doucement la sur la petite
animation à gauche eh bien il va
découper des petites îles des petites
roches qui sont un peu plus en hauteur
et on peut imaginer que quiberon bah si
on remonte un peu niveau marin au niveau
de l'isthme la pelouse ça va venir
et il m'a y avait un exemple que
j'aimais bien aussi c'était pour mes
collègues la du cotentin
il ya des cherbourg qui pouvait devenir
une île aussi parce qu'il y avait le
bassin de 40 ans qui est un peu plus bas
et donc ça pouvait mal à changer le
paysage et du coup on était en train de
fabriquer les îles et dans le projet d
imaginaire de la mer qu'on a menées il
ya quelques années avec les collègues de
l'université de nantes aussi on a eu la
chance d'accueillir un collègue
australien un patrimoine et qui lui par
contre s'intéresser aux terres qui
disparaissent d'un particulier les
territoires submergés et les îles qui
disparaissent en qui on a eu en bretagne
et lui la plus tôt interrogé les les
habitants de du littoral australien et
c'était très intéressant parce que il a
essayé de comparer en fait la mémoire
vernaculaire donc ces savoirs ancestraux
ces légendes aussi autour de ces
territoires immergé avec une chronologie
historique donc il a essayé de croiser
avec des écrits et il ya une bonne
concomitance alors c'est intéressant de
d'avoir ces phénomènes cette mémoire
parce que effectivement là aussi un les
le territoire a énormément changé les
paysages auront changé et aussi les gens
se sentent adapter son partie des
littoraux ils sont allés ailleurs et il
ya une problématique derrière cette ses
recherches de faire faire passer le
message finalement que c'est pas une
fatalité qu'effectivement le niveau
d'eau monte mais qu'il y a ça s'est déjà
produit qui fournit accepter aussi
finalement de peut-être de recul et un
petit peu quand il le faut et que
donc le fait de faire une science
participative ça a été extrêmement
intéressant sur ces territoires
mais là il s'agissait plutôt de
disparition de disparition est ce que tu
dis ça me fait penser que justement sur
l'île d'yeu il ya eu tout un travail
enfin il ya tout un travail en ce moment
justement ce projet il est collaboratif
échos participatif et donc l'idée c'est
de vraiment pour comprendre ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est de se baser
sur les observations des gens qui sont
vraiment sur place et qui ont cette
conscience et qu'ils ont ce don de
l'observation pour regarder peut-être
des petits détails puisque en fait c'est
souvent sec ce qui se passe dans la
nature il se passe pas grand chose enfin
on a l'impression en tout cas qu'il se
passe pas grand chose et tout d'un coup
de top qui a un petit équilibre qui se
défait on arrive dans un petit
déséquilibre un petit a prévu justement
ça peut être une barrière littoral qui
cassent une dune qui s'effondre parce
qu'il ya eu plus d'eau plus de quelque
chose et hop on passe dans un autre
système et pas qu'on se décale un peu et
on est en train de refaire un autre
équilibre qu on est en train de
rechercher
est ce que tu me dis c'est parce que je
me souviens quand on avait parlé avec
des gens sur les lieux il y avait des
nominations comme ça c'était le grand
trait le petit prêt je monte des roches
qui sont maintenant plus vraiment collé
à la côte sur les dieux mais qui sont
sous l'eau mais qui devait probablement
dans les temps anciens être des endroits
où on pouvait aller à pied sec et qu'ils
savaient de près par exemple de choses
comme ça
et du coup nous en tant que scientifique
on peut à la fois essayer de recueillir
7 7 7 se savoir la évidemment essayer de
représenter et de comprendre la nature
des risques
et aussi d'éclairer les décisions pour
essayer de s'en prémunir et s'adapter et
faire face lorsqu'il ya des imprévus qui
sont négatifs parce que heureusement il
y en ad positif et là on les accueille
plutôt de façon réjouissante mais
malheureusement il faut quand même
s'adapter et anticiper des phénomènes
qui peuvent être négatif donc notre rôle
par ses recherches pluridisciplinaires
et par cette ce recueil de savoir c'est
aussi finalement d'éclairer en utilisant
tout ce qu'on sait sur le retour sur le
passé et proposait donc essayer d'avoir
des diagnostics un savoir qu'elle se
sent qu'elle est la vulnérabilité des
territoires quelle est la probabilité
pour qu'un tel phénomène se reproduise
et proposer des solutions qui peuvent
puisse permettre de s'adapter
alors il ya des solutions qui sont un
peu brutal on quitte le littoral en
recul ou bien on fait des solutions en
dur on connaît tous ce qui est digue sur
le littoral mais aujourd'hui on a quand
même une réflexion aussi sur d'autres
solutions qui sont un petit peu plus
flexible qui peuvent être sur
l'aménagement du bâti mais aussi à des
solutions de digues dites douces
oui je faisais bien toi dans le oui dans
le littoral on a beaucoup de plus en
plus plutôt que de faire des choses des
enrochements des choses qui sont stables
et sûrs
enfin pour mieux s'adapter c'est plus
facile d'avoir des solutions douces des
branchages et justement où des
cheminements qui sont différents et je
pense que maintenant qu'on a compris
qu'il fallait penser en bas en faisant
en boucle en recyclant nos idées
peut-être et des solutions qui sont
temporaires les au bon moment par
exemple face à une tempête et qu'on peut
enlever après ça s'apprend c'est
probablement des solutions qui vont être
les plus efficaces c'est à dire pas des
choses qui restent justement rigide et
droite d'antan c'est des choses qu'il
faut être imaginé temporaires qu'ils
soient sous qu'on puisse et enlever les
remettre les remettre au bon endroit et
parce que là aussi je pense que la
localisation de ces
de ces défense doit être choisie très
très très de façon très précise et les
avantages d'avoir ce type de da proches
c'est déjà d'accepter le fait qu' il n'y
a pas une solution unique qui soit
applicable à tous les atouts les
littoraux et également de re mettre
vraiment l'accent sur la conscience du
risque parce que avec des choses qui
sont flexibles qui sont pas pérennes et
bien on permet aussi à chacun d'eux
d'être acteur de cette prévention et de
remettre un petit peu le poids sur la
prévention des risques et sur la culture
du risque donc vraiment faire participer
les habitants pas avoir des décisions
qui sont descendantes mais c'est le cas
on a vraiment une réflexion a vraiment
très bien plus récente la nature je suis
en train de déjeuner faire un imprévu de
micro là qui va tous deux groupes qui
veulent partir
dans cette conscience du risque c'est je
pense en fait c'est que l'homme l'avait
oublié il avait juste oublié qu'il était
dans un environnement qui risquait est
là en ce moment on est dans nos cycles
où justement on voit la conjonction de
plusieurs phénomènes et tout d'un coup
on reprend notre conscience du risque
on le voit tous les jours en ce moment
je pense en est quand même à un petit
peu dedans et ça c'est important par
contre il faut pas voir ce risque comme
quelque chose de d'insurmontable non
parce qu'il ya des imprévus qui sont
déjà positif
et puis il faut être capable de 200
saisir de rebondir et puis finalement de
s'adapter de ce que l'on appelle
maintenant la résilience mais oui c'est
la suisse et ses risques qui nous font
aussi avoir une perception enfin de
notre environnement parce qu'on a envie
oublier un petit peu que l'environnement
ça comptait aussi
et du coup de réfléchir d'avoir une
perception est justement de réfléchir
mieux donc en fait finalement plus là on
a eu pas mal d'imprévus en même temps
donc on a été obligé de réfléchir un peu
vite mais c'est vrai que ça fait avancer
la science là on
on l'entend à tous les niveaux et c'est
vrai que en fait il faut se servir de
ces imprévus et de ses risques pour
aller plus loin dans d'autres directions
explorer ddd direction de nouvelles et
il y avait une phrase que j'aimais bien
je me souviens plus c'était de jean
jouzel qui était il faut être audacieux
il faut être audacieux pour aller plus
loin mais c'est exactement ça faut qu'on
essaye de nouvelles choses et les
risques ou les imprévus vont nous
pousser à faire ça parce qu'autrement on
va rester plan-plan en attendant que ça
passe et la main ça y est on est obligés
de faire quelque chose et d'avancer de
façon différente et il est aussi en
alerte en alerte sur notre environnement
sur les modifications que l'on voit je
crois que tu as un très bel exemple à
nouveau à la wii ce quelque chose d'un
imprévu positif
un joli imprévu un imprévu magique et là
aussi qui souligne l'importance que tout
le monde soit acteur dans cette
justement cette conscience du risque
nos classes et on est sur l'île d'yeu
sur la plage des sapins et là ce que
vous voyez c'est une affleurements de
tourbe donc la tour en fait c'est un
ancien marais qui a été mise à nue et
donc se marrer il a fait cette tourbe 7
affleurements tourbe elle a été signalée
dans le cadre du projet odyssée yeux par
les gens dit dieu qui ont dû il ya un
truc bizarre sur la plage il faut que
l'on avertisse légende ou des ses yeux
donc là en l'occurrence elsa cariou en
luttant ouailles un drôle de truc c'est
peut-être un vieux plaquage la de mazout
des du torrey canyon ou un truc comme ça
et en fait elle a est allé voir et pas
du tout c'était en affirmant de tourbe
et donc pour le géologue marin c'est
génial la tourbe parce que ça va
conserver des empreintes
donc si tu as eu des habitants s'il ya
eu des animaux et c'est à toi que tu vas
récupérer des empreintes et donc c'est
une dame qui était sur l'île d'yeu
cadiot ben là il ya vraiment quelque
chose d'intéressant sur cette plage
venez voir donc finalement on a réussi
juste c'était la fin du premier
confinement est donc dès qu'on a eu le
droit de partir sur l'île d'yeu en y est
allé puisqu'elle était fermée ligneux et
donc on s'est précipité sur cette tourbe
on était tous contents et on voit très
très bien il ya des traces de bovidés
qu'on voit très bien sur la tourbe
peut-être même des traces de charette et
alors là c'était génial parce que
comme tous les scientifiques ont fait
plein de projection sur la comète on
raconte plein de choses et on a fait des
carottes et donc notre taupe elle et je
te donne en mille on avait le choix
entre moyen-âge 3000 ou ces mid moi et
je vais tenter 3000 arrêté bien jouer et
donc ça veut dire c'était une période où
le niveau marin il s'est arrêté un petit
peu donc on a eu le temps de faire
démarrer en arrière d'une et donc ses
marais en arrière du nil ont pu
enregistrer comme ça les traces d'éviter
et on a pu avoir comme ça c'est ce
magnifique affleurements qu'on a
vraiment bien dessiné des payer carotter
donc on est en train de faire plein
plein de données sur ce bel
affleurements peut-être que dans cinq
mille ans ce sera le marais poitevin
peut-être pas pleurer mais là l'endroit
qui était chouette enfin là aussi c'est
pour ça que c'était vraiment un petit un
petit coffre aux trésors qui s'était
ouvert et puis qui s'est refermée parce
qu'on est retourné en août et puis ben
il avait partiellement et et hop plus
que partiellement il avait un peu
carrément disparu avec le sable qui
était revenue dessus avec l'érosion
naturelle des gens des vagues et tout et
tout et donc c'est ça il faut qu'on soit
en alerte toujours pour prendre ces
petits pépins d'un prévues un peu
partout pour pouvoir justement avoir des
renseignements sur ce qui s'est passé
avant et raconter cette histoire
déroulée cette histoire dans le fait
dérouler tu vois tu refais ton histoire
dure cycle ton histoire en fait on est
vraiment dans ce ce mouvement là pour
mieux comprendre
je te jure qu'il vaut mieux regarder en
a pas pas mieux mais il faut aussi
regarder en arrière et garder la mémoire
ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui qui va nous aider
pendant toutes les années à venir
puisque l'art et ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ça et puis les solutions
qu'on est qu'on a à proposer
elles doivent être recyclables avec
l'idée que ça doit pouvoir partir dans
un cycle quel que soit le cycle et
qu'elle soit pas figée sur une durée
puisque c'est quand même un petit peu
comme ça qu'on réfléchisse quand on
prend des décisions en général on a un
horizon temporel et après cet horizon
temporel 20 on n'a pas anticipé ce qui
peut se passer
et si ces solutions sont plus flexibles
plus recyclable et bien on va arriver à
peut-être être un peu plus près à
appréhender des phénomènes qui sont
négatifs et plus on amène les gens les
alors évidemment moi je pense aux jeunes
aux collégiens à ceux qui sont en train
de se former d'apprendre plus on est
conscients des risques plus on apprend
et plus on apprend plus on va s'adapter
et plus on est tous ensemble comme ça
attentif et on veille et on va justement
être d'accord avec telle ou telle
solution
on est capable d'infléchir telle ou
telle solution parce qu'on connaît bien
son environnement et c'est vraiment
l'importance voilà l'homme est vraiment
d'anciens de l'environnement s'il veut
lui allait bien il faut que son
environnement à bien et ça à toutes les
échelles donc là nous c'est sur une
échelle du nil et c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que on apprend plein
de choses il ya un échange et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut pas mettre les
scientifiques sur un piédestal très très
loin et qui servent à rien non au
contraire on est là pour éclairer pour
aider et on apprend nous-mêmes beaucoup
beaucoup de choses des gens qui sont
surface mon exclusion cette mémoire du
lieu et cette mémoire du temps très fine
à très haute fréquence en fait que nous
on n'a pas forcément où on oublie un peu
dans nos grandes quand on a la mémoire
courte ça c'est en a la mémoire qui voit
là et même jour ajoute ça on a la
mémoire courte c'est penser mieux pensée
bouclé il faut vraiment faire ce
mouvement là pour essayer de refaire
airs comprendre mieux les choses quitte
à les revisiter quitta les revisiter et
pour ça
être capable de les re questionner avec
un regard différent et c'est un petit
peu ce qu'on fait quand même dans ses
recherches interdisciplinaires très
intéressés qui sont vraiment importantes
pour justement apporter une idée
nouvelle et un angle un éclairage lan
éclairage auquel on compense pas
toujours pas tout seul dans son coin ça
c'est vraiment important et il ya
probablement justement là tout dépend à
faire avec ces modélisations enfin là on
en parle beaucoup du numérique et je
pense qu'effectivement ça peut être des
outils est extrêmement important pour
faire rejouer pour continuer pour faire
du futur pour dessiner du futur ça ça
peut être ça peut faire aussi réfléchir
d'une autre façon plus on réfléchit avec
des éclairages différents
plus on ira loin ensemble ça c'est
vraiment je pense le maître mot de ces
de toutes les recherches qu'on peut
mener et accepter le temps le temps l'on
va là parce que le temps de la recherche
c'est pas forcément le temps de l'action
et
et si on a justement ce temps long de
recherche de recherche aussi un peu plus
théorique impact fondamental
eh bien peut-être que lorsqu'il s'agit
de réagir à des événements comme on
l'est on a évoqué tout à l'heure avec
les tempêtes mais ça peut être aussi des
épidémies ou autre chose
eh bien on a peut-être on n'est plus en
mesure d'avoir des réactions plus rapide
mais ce qu'on a ce temps long parce que
sinon ben on sait très bien que on a du
temps on a besoin de temps pour avoir
des solutions vocales à cesser les atc
de temps le temps l'on doit se dérouler
tranquillement et le temps court de
temps en temps au fond on a une petite
pépite qui nous fait accélérer ainsi de
suite le temps loin de la recherche est
extrêmement important il faut pas
l'oublier
même si le l'homme est là un temps de
vie qui est un peu petit mais il a la
recherche se poursuit
et ça c'est des choses qui sont vraiment
importantes surtout dans nos sociétés où
tout va très très vite là maintenant et
on aimerait avoir des solutions comme ça
mais elles sont encore possibles sophie
et merci aussi à vous agnès je vous
invite à me rejoindre et à vous asseoir
ici d'un coin salon pour les questions
des internautes qui sont nombreuses
[Musique]
alors votre première question
asseyez-vous agnès quand vous proposais
d' accepter de reculer un peu
quid des pays-bas et bien les pays bas
ils sont bien en avant sur 12 justement
les pays bas ça fait bien des années
qu'ils ont bien compris que le niveau
marin il était plus haut ils ont déjà
commencé a justement à déménager des
villages qui était le long sur le long
des canaux parce que il ya une chose une
conscience qu'il faut avoir c'est que
quand le niveau marin remonte en fait il
ya les rivières qui sont branchés sur la
mer qui vont s'élargir c'est à dire
qu'ils vont prendre plus de place qui
voit dans leurs ligues majeures dans
toutes nos rivières elles vont avoir
tendance à pout c'est aller un peu de
chaque côté et les petits villages qui
sont sur le bord des chenaux ou des
rivières eux aussi même s'ils sont pas
sûrs littoral ils vont avoir comme ça
une des conséquences de cette remontée
du niveau marin et les pays bas ça fait
déjà des années qu'ils sont en train de
déménager leur petit village même de
condamner carrément certains villages
donc ils sont bien en avance sur nous
parce qu'ils dépendent de leur
environnement depuis le début donc ils
sont bien plus attentif et j'avais lu 1
un papier qui était hyper intéressant
parce qu'il ya des morceaux de digues
qui vont même carrément abandonné c'est
même pas la peine donc il ya vraiment
des endroits il faut laisser passer la
mère et deux endroits on se concentre
pour essayer de se surélever ou d'aller
plus loin et donc on a beaucoup à
apprendre des pays bas l'angleterre
aussi à d'avant sur nous et nous on a un
peu cette on est en train vraiment je
pense que c'est que cynthia qui a été
vraiment le ça a changé beaucoup de
choses mais parce que malheureusement il
ya eu de la déception liée à cette
tempête
donc ça a changé beaucoup de choses et
effectivement il faut accepter parfois
de reculer ou bien de ne pas entretenir
des ouvrages et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est un petit peu nouveau 1 en france
en tout cas ce que fait font très bien
les pays bas malgré la mémoire des
événements les hommes manquent
franchement d'anticipation face à eux on
le constate tous les jours ça c'est un
constat est ce que partager ou pas ce
point de vue puisque vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter ou non a ajouté mme et
moi j'irai vraiment dans ce sens là et
je pense que plus on le dit plus ce ben
justement ans qu'on se rende vraiment
compte que l'histoire et d'un bal se
répète mais on s'est un petit peu qu'est
ce qui va se passer
il faut en prendre conscience en prendre
acte et réagir il faut pas rester
passifs en fait c'est ça l'idée c'est de
mieux comprendre pour se dire ok c'est
vrai que ça s'était passé comme ça
l'at-on exemple quand tu montres est la
limite justement de là
des eaux des eaux d'un vrai pas un top
ça reprenait sa place sa place naturelle
l'homme il a gagné pendant un temps mais
après il va de toute façon se refaire un
on va dire gagner par la mère et celle
qui gagnera tout seul à la fin mais moi
je suis pas de complètement d'accord
quand même sur le fait que les hommes
n'anticipe pas je pense qu'il ya
vraiment des attitudes et on le voit
aussi bien dans les modèles que dans le
canton fait des expérimentations là
dessus il ya vraiment des attitudes
différentes
1 il ya aussi une conscience du risque
qui est extrêmement forte
les habitants du littoral certains
travaillent la mer depuis des décennies
des générations ils savent très bien ce
que ces phénomènes peuvent arriver donc
les anticipations elles sont elles sont
quand même le lot de certains mais c'est
pas partager donc on a vraiment c'est de
ces différences d'appréhension des
phénomènes et encore une fois je cite l
exemple de xyntha tout à l'heure avec
cette probabilité sans tonale
c'est vrai qu'à l'échelle de l'être
humain un retour de cet événement dans
100 ans
ça part et ça paraît infini mais mais
tous les agents ne réagissent pas comme
ça on peut très bien se dire c'est
arrivé donc ça peut encore arriver et
donc avoir au contraire un besoin
d'anticiper ou de se prémunir contre les
risques
donc c'est pas aussi manichéen quand
même c'est pas manichéen mais marquante
ce c'est toujours on revient à la
mémoire on en parle beaucoup toutes les
deux avaient marre parce qu'en fait il
ya aussi beaucoup de gens ils ont des
maisons au bord de la mer mais diaby pas
au bord de la mer ils viennent d'une
autre grande ville ou de quelques pas et
tout d'un coup ils viennent juste pour
dt s'en souvenir que peut-être pendant
l'hiver ou à d'autres moments il ya des
choses qui se passent et cette mémoire
ils peuvent pas l'avoir puisqu'ils ont
jamais invité là est donc là il ya aussi
un décalage entre qu'est ce qui peut se
passer avec cette maison pourquoi la
pauvre elle est bientôt dans l'eau je
comprends pas alors que elle a toujours
été là et ça aussi justement comme il ya
cette accélération en ce moment de ces
événements il ya des gens ne comprennent
pas pourquoi leur maison à la 300 ans
mais là maintenant tout d'un coup elle
est en danger donc c'est pas parce
qu'elle a 300 en cadets - danger
là aussi il ya cette espèce de travail
bit
oui exactement les digues 12 sont elles
vraiment viable sur le long terme
et bien justement si on fait des dites
douces ou en fait c'est justement pas
des digues c'est forcément en fait mal
quand je parlais de dick douce c'est
parce que j'ai vu un exemple en fait
c'est des espèces d'énormes blocs en
plastique très très durs qu'on va mettre
comme ça pendant trois quatre jours à un
endroit qu'on sait particulièrement
fragile et qui vont être juste là
pendant les 3 4 jours de cette énorme
tempête avec ce grand coefficient et
ainsi de suite et on sait que ça va
tenir pendant ces quelques jours là et
après on les enlève
et du coup on n'a pas besoin de dépenser
des millions et des millions d'euros
pour faire une énorme dit qu' un jour ou
l'autre va partir en petits morceaux et
au contraire ça à partir du moment où
ces calibres et où c'est au bon endroit
parce que vraiment je pense que la
localisation est la plus en plus
importante maintenant que je commence à
avoir quelques exemples en tête
on voit vraiment qu'il ya des endroits
il faut faire quelque chose d'autre
endroit c'est pas la peine et on est
dans ce changement climatique et on sait
maintenant que la cause des tempêtes il
est en train de changer un petit peu
puisque voilà on a des tempêtes qui vont
venir un peu plus vers le web le sud sud
ouest
donc voilà il ya tout un équilibre qui
va changer en sa chance à ben dodik je
pense qu'il y en a quelques-unes elles
savent plus rien ils sont plus tout à
fait dans le bon sens par rapport à ce
qui va arriver mais en dans les digues
douce on peut penser aussi aux dunes aux
cordes wilmerhale en entretien et qui
sont une excellente protection face à
ces épisodes là et
et là on est quand même en train
notamment sur le littoral
vendirent suite à xynthia où on
entretient ses cordes ou binaire et mais
ce qui est intéressant je trouve dans
ses solutions temporaires c'est que elle
demande des tracteurs encore une fois on
va aller poser parce qu'on a anticipé le
phénomène parce qu'on est la
connaissance parce qu'on sait qu'à un
moment donné ça peut se produire et donc
ça ne repose la question de la
conscience du risque et de ce point de
vue là je pense que c'est assez durable
comment se fait-il
agnès sophie que le risque d'inondation
n'affecte pas à la baisse le prix des
maisons au port de mer faisait alors là
à liège j'ai dit alors ceux qui doit
vous écoute ça c'est toujours le
paradoxe parce qu'on voit en gros si je
schématise à la limite de la caricature
le niveau monte et les prix montent
aussi voyez avec les prix une
concentration quand même des habitants
sur le littoral qui est extrêmement
forte et qui n'arrête pas de croître
alors l'attrait de la mer
la mémoire courte aussi parce que ces
phénomènes encore une fois ne sont pas
non plus aussi récurrent de sa e
peuvent expliquer ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un point qui est toujours
étonnant de voir que les prix de
l'immobilier ne baisse pas donc c'est
vraiment la traction et puis il faut
quand même voir aussi que une grande
partie des des habitations au littoral
ne sont pas occupés toute l'année ils ne
sont occupés que quelques mois de
l'année et l'été c'est pas là où il ya
les plus grandes tempêtes
donc ça explique aussi la pression
foncière elle est allée extrêmement
importante et elle s'explique aussi par
la nature de l'occupation de ces
habitations qui sont pas seulement des
habitations principales
vous parliez de tempête justement les
phénomènes naturels extrêmes tels que
cynthia seront ils mieux prévu quand nos
modèles seront plus performants ou bien
il ya toujours une limite à notre
technologie
là je pense aussi pour cynthia enfin tu
connais mieux mais moi le peu que j'ai
entendu cynthia c'était quand même assez
incroyable parce que quand on a on est
un peu allez travailler justement sur
cette pointe et en fait c'était un grand
coefficient les grands coefficients on
sait très bien quand est ce qu'ils
arrivent donc ils sont prévues des
années à l'avance la tempête elle était
prévu puisque la météo france étaient
est en fait là aussi c'était la
méconnaissance qu'est ce que ça peut
faire une grosse tempête avec une
surcote +1
un grand coeff de marais qui fait que la
marée haute elle va être évidemment à
minuit ou tard le soir
on le sait ça mais c'est une
méconnaissance générale et on n'a pas
perçu le danger
en fait là maintenant justement je pense
que ça a quand même fait une mais c'est
surtout que la concomitance des
événements c'est effectivement le plus
hauts coefficients de marée avec la la
la la plus haute intensité de la tempête
ça c'est quelque chose en termes de
probabilité qui est extrêmement faible
donc en fait le modèle peut prévoir que
ça peut arriver mais c'est tellement
rare comme élevé comme événement que on
l'a pas anticiper on n'a pas pas
vraiment cheap et moi j'ai entendu alors
je sais pas plus mais les les pêcheurs
en avait parlé
en fait c'était dit avait raconté que
normalement c'est quand et des grandes
marées on est toujours à peu près marée
basse en mi-journée vers midi une heure
c'est marée basse et en fait ce qu'ils
avaient déjà remarqué c'est que le
niveau marin avait presque pas baissé on
était avait une telle surcote c'est à
dire qu'on était vraiment avec une
pression qui était super appuyé donc le
niveau marin n'est presque pas baissé
donc il pouvait que remonter encore plus
donc on était vraiment dans des
conditions extraordinaires et donc il
avait essayé d'avertir peut-être pas les
bonnes personnes c'est toujours pareil
il ya des messages ne passent pas au bon
endroit et donc du coup personne est
spécialement averti et on arrive à des
choses comme ça
cette tempête est assez imprévu
clairement à carhaix pour rebondir si je
peux me permettre
nos collègues historiens ne disait que
au moyen-âge avec le tocsin tu parlé d'
alerte
en fait les habitants réagissent et il y
avait des tempêtes forte
il y avait des submersions marines des
appels et des vies maire de vie demain
les e-mails
et pour autant les signaux d'alerté
était connu et là alors il y avait
évidemment une concentration beaucoup
moins forte sur les littoraux
mais les signaux étaient connus donc il
ya tout un travail sur les plans de
prévention des risques inondation ou on
travaille justement les les
collectivités territoriales travaillent
sur ces signaux d'alert sur cette
prévention sur la leyre tinseth
on peut pas travailler sur l'aléa on
peut pas empêcher que ça se passe et par
contre il y à des décisions à prendre
sur l'adaptation en fait de ces sociétés
et littoral est ce qu'une ils se forment
toujours en fonction des niveaux marins
non non non effectivement une île ça
peut être un volcan et il ya des volcans
enfin donc il ya des îles qui
apparaissent tout comme ça en quelques
heures et puis il y en a qui
disparaissent il y en a une très jolie
deal qui est en train de presque
apparaître c'est au sud de d comment ça
s'appelle des îles
elle est liée raw fuerteventura de
l'aider c'est pas les açores c'est
lesquels saisi la non dans tout cas y'a
jamais l'idylle comme ça et on a les
îles canaries voilà et donc au sud des
canaris à une petite île qui est en
train de venir personne n'avait prévu et
puis tout d'un coup elle est en train de
venir
donc il y en a effectivement c'est des
volcans et au tournoi effectivement
c'est du découpage par le niveau marin
qui remonte et quand se forme les îles
artificielles et c'est catastrophique
c'est le plus grand exemple c'est le
palmier l'abu dhabi la cette espèce de
gros pamiers monstrueux et alors
justement tu disais du sable tout à
l'heure en fait ses katas parce que ils
ont tabassé du sable du sable du ca pour
faire émerger ces il est en fait ce
sable qu'ils ont mis là évidemment il
l'a récupéré ailleurs et ça ça fait
partie des grands problèmes qu'on a là
c'est cette extraction du sable en
milieu marin qui fait que ce sable qui
n'existe plus ailleurs c'est-à-dire près
du vietnam près de l'indonésie ne va
plus pouvoir recharger les plages et
donc assurer leur défense a donc
l'indonésie cool parce qu'ils ont vendu
leur sable abu dhabi et il y avait cette
espèce d'énorme planisphère qui voulait
faire en il
ils ont jamais vu le jour en fait elles
ont raison pas pu s'ériger en fait à 12
heures à cause de ça parce qu'en plus le
sable c'est vraiment un état d'équilibré
il ya du sable à tel endroit avec cet
extrait taille de grains c'est parce que
c'est des conditions hydrodynamique qui
font ça on peut pas aller chercher du
sable à perpète et le matin ou si on
fait on va perdre beaucoup d'argent
oui c'est une catastrophe est exactement
c'est pas du tout des choses qu'on peut
interchanger le sable d'un endroit c'est
pas du tout le même sac que l'autre
endroit c'est à chaque fois
après il ya d'autres projets d'habiter
pour habiter la mer qui qui pourraient
être considérés comme des îles
artificielles mais qui sont pas des ide
elles sont vraiment des habitats
flottant oui c'est ça il ya des grands
projets alors c est là où c'est pas des
îles on tente à elle en tout cas on va
parler d'un autre projet le projet mose
aveu disent que pensez vous de ce projet
là est une solution sur le long terme
selon vous alors le projet
tu connais oui je te laisse commencé
parce que moi je suis très très très
négative parce qu'il adresse à 20
minutes tu te laisses très négative
d'accord en fait ce qui est en face et
on regarde injuste justement une carte
ça c'est sympa des cartes parce que ça
permet aussi de voir dans le temps parce
que on voit bien les zones de faiblesse
si on voit bien comment c'était avant et
on s'aperçoit que moss donc on a ces
espèces de grandes
porte en fer qui vont essayer de
canaliser la marée qui montre où des
tempêtes interviennent pour pâques
envahir la lagune de venise et en fait
on voit très bien que c'est entre des
petites lacunes comme ça des petites
langue de terre de sable et voit bien
que si celle-là de d'ailleurs ça marche
pas entre guillemets donc si cette porte
elle va vraiment coincé la mer à cet
endroit là la mère elle va passer juste
à côté
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
c'était un petit peu un drôle de projet
parce qu'ils avaient tellement envie de
sauver venise mais je pense que c'était
sauver venise pas pour les bonnes
raisons c'était sur venise parce que ça
ramène de l'argent
enfin moi je voyais ça plutôt d'un point
de vue économique nous la lui c'est ça
après c'est aussi le un pote patrimoine
culturel oui mais
mais là aussi c'est des défenses en dur
est effectivement assez d'accord avec
agnès c'est pas quelque chose qui paraît
tout à fait ni souhaitable ni durable en
tout cas comment sauver les villes
dernière question en littoral surtout
avec la fonte des glaces et les
mouvements marin ça dépend desquels oui
par exemple saint nazaire je sais qu'ils
sont en train de regarder justement pour
faire des maisons bas qui flotte sur des
caissons et des maisons sur pilotis
on va adapter nos façons d'habiter
justement sur le sur le littoral et je
pense qu'il est vraiment nécessaire de
laisser à certains endroits passé la mer
ouais c'est ça il faut tu la laisses
passer à cet endroit là et puis toi tu
te concentres sur un autonome et voilà
il faut partager
il faut l'accueillir il faut la laisser
passer parce que toute façon c'est elle
qui a un qui est forte
alors si on essaye de se battre contre l
on perd ça c'est évident mais c'est sûr
ah oui et c'est vrai que le littoral
enfin toutes les communes littorales
fort heureusement sont pas touchées de
la même manière donc c'est important
d'avoir un diagnostic sur la
vulnérabilité et d'accepter
effectivement de laisser la mer
reprendre sa place dans certains
endroits et peut-être au contraire dans
certains endroits où il ya des solutions
qui peuvent être apportées donc les
maisons pilotis de maisons flottantes
réhausser les habitats aussi tout
simplement tout simplement vous faire et
il y avait par exemple il faut voir
aussi que c'est pour ça que je lisais la
localité elle est vraiment importante
là on voit pas loin de chez nous par
exemple saint brevin n'est pas il ya
plein de sable
ils ont trop de sable ils ont peuvent
plus ils ont dû ça partout partout
partout donc aux îles on la change
d'être naturellement défendent dieu
contre tout ce qui est arrivé parce
qu'ils ont ces grandes dunes de sable
comme ça qu'a et protège et juste à côté
saint michel chef chef par exemple ou au
contraire ils sont en érosion
donc il ya vraiment des façons très très
fine
donc il faut regarder ce littoral est
considéré ce littoral est considéré ce
littoral sur du linéaire c'est à dire et
on regarde pas la petite boîte là il
faut qu'on regarde toutes les boîtes les
unes à côté des autres parce que chacune
va dépendre l'une de l'autre en plus
près ce que si penser au rétro-littoral
ou est-ce que si on pense à reculer un
petit peu ou en tout cas à répartir de
façon un petit peu différente les usages
du littoral ça veut dire aussi penser
aménagement du territoire
un peu plus loin donc c'est il ya pas
mal de questions quand même qu'ils se
posent sur sûre si l'adaptation avec
toutes les technologies dont on dispose
aujourd'hui pour suivre et gérer notre
environnement l'imprévu at il encore sa
place et ce sera notre dernière question
heureusement c'est notre moteur tiens
d'ailleurs prévu on peut rien faire pour
les chercheurs en tout cas c'est le
moteur du chercheur c'est l'imprévu et
justement c'est ça qui fait avancer
enfin j'ai l'impression que c'est le
sait là
c'est le sel c'est le statut c'est votre
moteur aussi wifi la technologie elle va
apporter des solutions
mais encore faut-il poser les bonnes
questions et est en général elle est là
pour apporter
oui des éléments de réponse mais
l'imprévu il est encore d'actualité en
environnement en sciences et
heureusement qu'il est là même dans la
technologie
yann imprévu un jeu si on peut pas tout
prévoir
voilà c'est ça c'est juste alger 2
s'achève outils et pierre antoine moreau
le disais tout à l'heure
et heureusement est heureusement bien
sûr c'est le sel de la vie merci
beaucoup merci ce fille mercy agnès
merci aussi à ceux qui nous ont rejoints
sur ce live tout de suite vous allez
découvrir la vidéo sciences de comptoir
réalisé par la youtube euse valentine
delattre et puis se suivront deux
conférences art science je le rappelle
poser toutes vos questions nos
intervenants y répondrons avec grand
plaisir
merci à toutes les deux pièces merci
vous allez donc découvrir dans quelques
instants la vidéo de la youtube us
valentine delattre valentine de là c'est
une journaliste scientifique et vidéaste
en 2015 elle décide de fonder avec deux
copines étudiantes et bien sa propre
chaîne youtube chances de comptoir
aujourd'hui et valentine y postent des
vidéos de vulgarisation sur la géologie
bourret au total 10 d'autodérision
pardon mais toujours très documenté et
oui son humour pince sans rire c'est sa
marque de fabrique
dans ces vidéos qui lui donne à nous les
spectateurs de très bons fous rires
alors valentine et en duplex avec nous
depuis montpellier on va la rejoindre
dans quelques instants
elle va nous rejoindre en attendant ce
que je veux ce que je veux dire c'est
que n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions à valentine elle se fera un
plaisir et bien d'y répondre
après cette vidéo
si vous allez voir c'est une vidéo où il
ya au programme des minéraux des
découvertes fortuites
le tout avec une bonne touche d'humour
on va voir on va regarder dans un
instant la vidéo et puis valentino ci va
vous décortiquez toute la géologie vous
allez voir que c'est une femme qui est
passionné par les cailloux les petits
cailloux etc un parcours assez atypique
elle était donc journalistes et
maintenant elle fait des vidéos d'humour
sur la géologie
un terme qui peut paraître au départ
discipline tout cas un petit peu
abstraite mais qui est bien est rendue
complètement drôle et concrète grâce à
valentine alors est-ce que valentine est
avec nous en duplex ou pas de vent
taulier est ce qu'on l'aperçoit ou pas
pas encore il joue pas parce que je vous
entends ce bonsoir parfait soir heureux
d'être avec vous ce soir en duplex
depuis montpellier
d'abord quand on regarde toutes vos
vidéos
il ya une bonne et belle touche d'humour
c'est votre marque de vote fabrique
c'est votre adn valentine oui c'est mon
fardeau avant tout parce que voilà quand
on est drôle au quotidien comme moi on
se doit de partager ce moment avec avec
tout le monde et spécialement ses
proches un fardeau c'est plutôt a plutôt
une qualité
oui oui mais au quotidien c'est
difficile parce que tout le monde
s'attend à ce que vous soyez drôle tout
le temps et il faut être inspiré dès le
matin vous comprenez c'est fatigant kaka
voilà c'est épuisant
quel est votre parcours je disais
rapidement que vous étiez journaliste
mais quel est votre parcours exact banc
valentine
mon parcours j'ai fait une licence en
géologie et après je suis revenu dans le
droit chemin que j'ai fait de la
biologie évolutive à montpellier et
après j'ai fait un master en journalisme
scientifique
voilà qui est pas mal accès audio visuel
donc maintenant je suis vidéaste slash
journaliste scientifique et ça consiste
en quoi le métier des géologues
alors personnellement j'ai jamais
vraiment été géoloc parce que je me suis
arrêté au stade d'étude hop c'était bien
déjà mais en gros de ce que j'ai pu voir
un géologue et une partie sur le terrain
évidemment il ya une partie aussi en
laboratoire il y en a qui ont des
espèces de l'expérience en laboratoire
où ils essayent de reconstruire des
terrains et de les soumettre à des
contraintes des tirs et de comprimés
pour voir comment enfin comment ça se
comporte pour reproduire des paysages
mais dans un dans un petit espace
et puis il ya une partie aussi de
modélisation en informatique
enfin voila c'est très complet le thème
ce soir valentine c'est l'imprévu quelle
est la part d'imprévu dans votre métier
dans vos vidéos
il ya énormément d'imprévus déjà le
choix du sujet ça peut être avant
d'écrire le script où ça peut être
pendant ça m'arrive de changer d'idée de
suggérer au fil des discussions de tous
comme ça gens là j'avais prévu dix
vidéos et en fait il s'avère que y en a
aucune qui part sur le sujet que j'avais
prévu de faire et puis après il ya toute
la partie tournage qui qui souvent ça
dérape un peu ça fait n'importe quoi ou
alors c'est moi qui fais n'importe quoi
et des fois je me laisse entraîner dans
mes blagues et ça va plus loin que ce
que je veux et voilà
et comme ça m'amuse je le garde au
montage parce que je la moi qui fait le
montage aime beaucoup trop les là moi
qui ai au tournage
et si ces prétentieux ne se dédoubler
comme ça j'en suis ravi et ça fait des
bonnes touches d'humour dans vos vidéos
si j'essaye en tout cas d'où vient cette
passion finalement pour les cailloux
depuis tout petit
depuis tout petit alors passion pour les
cailloux sts bien grand mot disons j'ai
toujours été fasciné par la collection
oui vous avez parlé avec passion
bah j'essaye gsm et c'est parce que
c'est intéressant comme sujet et puis on
sans doute pas enfin quand on voit des
cailloux par terre on se dit pas on se
dit pas que en fait c'est des témoins de
plusieurs millions d'années de
l'histoire de la terre et c'est
peut-être que tous asséné quand je
jouais avec la collection de minéralogie
de mon frère qui avait une petite boîte
avec plein de petits minéraux savez on
trouve souvent des trucs comme ça ça
peut être des cadeaux de noël ou des
choses comme ça et ça va toujours
beaucoup fasciné tous ces petits
minéraux et de voir la diversité des
choses qu'on pouvait trouver sur terre
voilà c'est ça devient votre passion je
pense que ça vient de là ce soir juste
avant de lancer cette vidéo quels sont
les ingrédients
quels sont les pour faire cette recette
qu'on va découvrir dans quelques
instants
alors des ingrédients dans votre vie
déroule pas se retrouver
oui on va trouver de cailloux on va
trouver des mauvaises blagues et un
petit peu de savoir à quoi tout ça dans
une vidéo qu'on va pouvoir regarder dans
quelques instants
pensez à poser toutes vos questions à
valentine il y aura un temps des changes
après la diffusion de cette vidéo que je
vous laisse regarder
voilà regarder tout de suite
ce dame est ce que vous connaissez
l'histoire du marteau leur fou rené
juste à huy est un jeune abbé de
province sans histoire non mais regardez
moi c'était rare non moi je lui confie
volontiers mes enfants à condition que
ce soit pas les miens c'est le mec qui
est derrière la sur cette image
l'auteur bissell son frère valentin qui
a fait plein de trucs pour les aveugles
mais ça c'est une autre histoire
or donc c'est par accident que ce fieffé
à huy le curé a inventé tout un pan de
la géologie
la légende raconte qu'un jour où ce
qu'ils avaient des moufles à la place
des mains et la tête dans le xi et gore
sa wii a fait tomber par terre un
malheureux cristal de quel site et pas
sous ses yeux globuleux dégoulinante
d'une intelligence féroce à fait non pas
des chocapics mais des petits cristaux
de calcite de la même forme géométrique
que le gros de départ des rambos aide à
8 notre honorable ab qui était aussi
géologue ce qui explique pourquoi il
joue avec des cailloux se dit m si je
continue à martyriser ce pauvre cristal
comme moi même je les ai été dans mon
enfance par mes camarades de classe
parce qu'on peut dire j'ai pas vraiment
gagner à la loterie de la vie est ce que
je vais continuer à obtenir des ronds
beau être de plus en plus petits et si
oui quand est-ce que ça s'arrête à
l'échelle de la molécule qui se dit etc
et sap et loriot la molécule intégrant
enfin maintenant on dit la maille comme
dans un tricot en fait selon phase de
fer by les attentes de notre calcite
s'arrange eux mêmes sous cette même
forme de rombeau est comme une brique de
lego pencher et en combinant ces briques
pencher on obtient notre gros cristal de
départ un peu comme si les cristaux
était du pixel art mais en 3d du côté du
voxel art
oui un pixel en 3d s'appelle un voxel
ici vraiment on se diversifie en diable
voilà donc l'hypothèse de notre père
ayew
oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
on l'a vérifié il saisit son marteau de
géologues et se met à des baumes et tous
les minéraux qui lui passe sous la main
pour voir ce qu'ils ont dans le ventre
imaginez juste un peu la scène georges
cuvier himself rapporte monsieur à huy
n'hésite pas à mettre en pièces sa
petite collection
ces cristaux ce qu'il obtient de ses
amis il va être content éclater sous le
marteau
partout il retrouve une structure fondée
sur les mêmes lois du coup gargamel
n'était pas très très apprécié de ses
contemporains c'est étonnant il a même
hérité du surnom de cristal au
classement je sais pas vous moi je
trouve ça un peu classe comme nom de
serial killer dominer ou alors tout ça
c'est un peu comme newton et sa pomme
mais on sait pas trop ce qui relève de
la réalité et ce qui relève du mythe
mais en tout cas c'est une belle
histoire et ce serait donc en ruinant sa
propre collection et celle de ses rares
copains qui a eu aurait inventé
accidentellement la cristallographie où
la science des cristaux et oui bon alors
j'entends déjà les puristes qui vont
crier oulala alors évidemment c'est pas
uniquement grâce aux productions
scientifiques de notre abbé il yad
autres géologues ont permis de fonder
cette discipline misant sur la science
efforts collectifs tout ça comme le bon
rom est de l'île voilà comme ça c'est
dit kevin tu es venger tu peux retourner
manger tes pêche au thon et alors ce
qu'ont découvert notre gang de
cristallographe c'est donc que tous les
minéraux qu'on connaît sont formés de
briques répété à l'envi tel un pavage en
quelque sorte
voilà la soumettent les matheux dans la
poche que voulez vous je suis démago oui
à la nature non aux arômes artificiels
sauf que toutes les briques de départ
n'ont pas toujours la même forme c'est
pas toujours des briques pencher comme
pour laquelle site
et oui aux lego store du géologue on
peut choisir entre cette forme de
briques défini par la longueur des
arêtes et les angles entre les fasse ce
qui nous donne cette système cristal ou
cubique quadratique hexagonal rombaut
hedrick or toru big money cliniques et
précliniques ce qui veut dire qu'on peut
ranger tous les 5600 minéraux ou connaît
aujourd'hui parmi cette forme
géométrique chaque minérale est ensuite
obtenu en retaillant dans ses formes
primitives à lui on a même fait des
modèles en bois de c'est cette forme on
peut on observer dans quelques musées
parce qu'il en a fait d'état notamment
au musée de minéralogie de l'école des
mines à paris que je vous invite
vivement à aller visiter dans le monde
d'après parce que c'est vraiment mes
préférés dans son jus avec ses vieilles
petit armor et tout passe d'être cool et
vous pourrez même y voir le bureau de
votre marque leur fou puisqu'il était le
tout premier conservateur de ce musée
entre autres réalisations il
sa statue dans la galerie de minéralogie
du muséum national d'histoire naturelle
oui je suis un petit peu fan je vous
laisse aller voir sa page wikipédia ça
vous intéresse ou alors si vous êtes
chômeur et que du coup vous avez rien de
mieux à faire à part a cité le système
en volant le pain des honnêtes gens
comptent sur vous mais je m'égare ses
sept systèmes christelle à un peu comme
les sept nains mais en plus j'ai eu mes
tripes c'est un des critères essentiels
pour reconnaître un minéral et ça tombe
bien parce que figurez vous que c'est
justement l'objet de cette vidéo et oui
ce fut une très très longue introduction
mais ô combien plaisante
imaginez vous faites votre voile à
s'imaginer que je fais des vieux bruits
de bouche dégueulasse pas trop dur et
imaginer ça imaginez vous faites votre
promenade dominicale dans la nature
quand soudain en soulevant une crotte de
chien paf vous découvrez en minéral vous
savez pas ce que c'est mais vous mourrez
d'envié de le savoir eh bien vous êtes
au bon endroit grâce à moi vous allez
pouvoir identifier facilement les
minéraux les plus courants mais en plus
vous aurez perdu un quart d'heure de
votre vie alors déjà qu'est ce donc un
minéral me demandez-vous avidement et
bien cunégonde c'est un solide qui
présente une structure de cristal et une
composition chimique définissent house
house house a pas comme une roche donc
qui elle est un assemblage de minéraux
par exemple le gras ni encore lui
toujours lui est une roche qui contient
les minéraux quartz feldspath et mika
ces minéraux la semaine sous forme de
grains ont dit que la roche a une
texture grenu si vous vous souvenez de
la vidéo sur la bouillabaisse nous ici
on va plutôt s'intéresser aux minéraux
mastoc le gens qu'on trouve dans les
musées ou chez les naturopathes pour
soigner la qualité de votre corps et
surtout l'hypertrophie de votre porte
monnaie a laissé mardi pour commencer
outre la forme du minéral le premier
critère qui vous viendra spontanément en
tête si vous êtes normalement constitué
c'est la couleur est effectivement
certains minéraux sont très
identifiables par leur couleur c'est le
cas du soufre natifs qui est encore plus
jeune que le blanchisseur de lucky luke
mais méfiez vous parce que c'est pas
toujours aussi évident regardez tous ces
machins sont une seule et même espèce
minérale de la fluorite eh oui selon les
impuretés qu'elle contient elle peut
être choix incolore bleues vertes jaunes
blanches roses brune noir violette rouge
ou pourpre la floride c'est la gay pride
elle toute seule
après la couleur la transparence
certains minéraux sont transparents
comme le quartz ou la floride d'autres
sont translucides comme la gamme et
d'autres complètement opaque comme
le cuivre la pyrite la galène où les
comptes de campagne de françois fillon
dans le même genre toujours on a aussi
les classes est ce que votre minérale va
renvoyer fort la lumière qu'il reçoit
comme un miroir c'est le cas de la
pyrite par exemple on dit que son éclat
et métallique est ce qu'il est plutôt
adamantin comme le diamant d'où son nom
est ce que l'éclat eu plutôt vitre comme
le quartz gras comme votre mère ou comme
le talent perlé comme les mika qui sont
même un petit peu et riz descendez fois
ou alors mat comme l'argile et c'est là
qu'on voit que le géologue est un peu
poète aussi au fond bien au fond pour
faut creuser partout humour après il ya
aussi la densité en soupesant votre
caillou à la main est ce qui vous paraît
loulou mouvement lourd qu'un caillou
standard concile est particulièrement
dense sa peine de la galène sinon
l'hématite et la pyrite sont pas mal
danse aussi
alors maintenant la trace sa série good
run une feuille blanche et servez vous
de votre minérales comme moi crayon oui
vous êtes géologue maintenant vous devez
tout faire avec des cailloux de quelle
couleur est la trace que votre
échantillon laisse sur le papier vous
pouvez avoir des surprises avec ce test
si on prend deux minéraux noir qui se
ressemblent et qui sont tous les deux
des oxydes de fer l'hématite et la
goethite la première va laisser une
trace rouge sang et la deuxième une
trace jaune ocre donc malgré les
apparences c'est pas les mêmes créés
d'une couleur alors maintenant le
clivage ici on cause pas de décolleté un
milieu pauvre bil'in qui nous regardent
omelette de fromage c'est la manière
dont le minéral se casse
est-ce qu'il se brise selon des plans
préférentielles dans l'espace par
exemple notre calcite elle va se casser
tout net en petit robot est trop bien le
mica il va s'effeuiller comme une
danseuse burlesque on parle de plantes
clivages à ce moment là et si au
contraire il y en a pas de plan de
clivage plus ou moins nettes on parle de
cassure comme la fameuse caisse sur con
côté dale qui va rappeler des souvenirs
aux habitués de la chaîne
regardez bien votre minérale est ce
qu'il a l'air d'avoir pris à un pet
comme le cul d'une bouteille en verre ce
qui fait apparaître des espèces de
cercle au concentré oui je les aime
beaucoup ses cercles concentriques et
ben ça c'est une question qu'on corrida
c'est un excellent moyen de reconnaître
l'obsidienne qui est du verre naturel à
l'intérieur ces attentes sont
complètement en vrac ce qui explique que
ça se casse n'importe où n'importe
comment s'en suivent deux plan bien
défini
maintenant la mcl parfois vous pouvez
voir plusieurs cristaux du même minérale
qui sont enchevêtrées et la manière dont
ils se mélangent c'est ce qu'on appelle
la mcl et ça aussi ça peut nous
renseigner sur le nom du minéral sus
mentionnés par exemple le gypse peut
avoir plusieurs genres de mac dont une
typique en fer de lance et la star au
tydos y en a plusieurs dont une que je
trouve assez classe c qui s'appelle en
croix de saint-andré voilà de quoi vous
la péter lors des prochains repas de
fête surtout si vous voulez qui se
termine plus vite alors la suite fait
intervenir un peu
ici par un heureux hasard vous vous
baladez avec une fiole d'acide
chlorhydrique sur vous ou au pire un peu
de vinaigre blanc ça tombe bien fait
tomber quelques gouttes sur un point
d'eau minérale un coin que vous aimez
pas trop au cas où et si sa bulle et
samui rica vous avez trouvé un carbonate
probablement de laquelle c'est notre
copine aux briques penchait du début est
dans le même genre si ça se dissout dans
l'eau ou si c'est une partie de mon
gosse en live avec le raptor sardo chez
gérard ya ça peut être du sel un autre
critère essentiel pour identifier un
minéral l'échelle qui nous sert à
estimer la dureté des minéraux c'est à
dire la facilité avec laquelle on peut
les réparent exemple vous pouvez rayer
le talk à l'ongle et si vous prenez un
bout de quartz vous pourrez rayer un
verre avec plutôt que de ruiner votre
propre vaissellerie allait plutôt
emprunté le vert de quelqu'un donc fait
comme à lui faites vous des amis
et si vous avez un diamant sous la main
vous pourrez y est absolument tout et
n'importe quoi avec c'est même le seul
intérêt à voir un diable mais attention
ça veut pas dire pour autant que le
diamant est incassable tel un bape tout
il est fragile ne vous amusez pas à
jouer au marteau leur fou avec la bague
de votre grand mère parce que oui à ce
moment là où vous allez la brise et son
super pouvoir c'est juste qu'on peut pas
le rayer sauf avec un doux dingue mais
on peut très bien le cas c'est en mille
morceaux ça n'a rien à voir par contre
si vous le cas c'est là vous obtiendrez
plein de petits cubes de diamants et
d'autres plus petits cubes après jusqu'à
la molécule intégrante elle-même cubique
merci à 8 maintenant même si c'est un
peu plus anecdotique
l'odeur et le goût vous souvenez du
soufre natif dont on a parlé au début et
qui est aussi jaune que tout le casting
des simpson réunis eh bien figurez-vous
qu'il a une délicieuse odeur très
caractéristique d'oeuf pourri la pyrite
aussi vu que elle contient aussi du sou
et si vous êtes d'humeur aventurière ou
si vous avez une bonne assurance vie
vous pouvez essayer de laisser votre
cailloux si ça goûte le sel bas c'est
que sans des six à un vieux goût salé
amer franchement dégueulasse
félicitations vous avez trouvé de la cl
vite je reprécise au passage même si
c'est plus développé dans cette vidéo là
qu'il faut éviter de lécher tout et
n'importe quoi parce que certains
cailloux sont toxiques un bien sûr en
plus vous savez pas quel point gaulin a
pu se soulager dessus avant votre
passage vous voudriez pas faire les gros
titres comme étant le géologue amateur
qui a fait émerger de nouvelles
pandémies
merci pour nommer mais voilà donc pour
les principaux critères d'identification
des minéraux il y en a beaucoup mais je
vous rassure il y en a encore d'autres
certains minéraux sont phosphorescent
d'hôtes sont fluorescent sous une
lumière noire vous pouvez emmener votre
collection avec vous en discothèque si
vous voulez vérifier d'autres encore
sont magnétiques comme suspense
l'allemagne et d'autres encore sont
radioactifs comme
la pêche blindes où mon chouchou le
zircon donc vous pouvez toujours
dégainez votre compteur geiger et un
autre truc très utile et je finirai
là-dessus dont on n'a pas parlé encore
c'est tout simplement l'endroit d'où
vient votre cailloux si vous avez la
chance de connaître sa provenance ou si
vous l'avez vous-même cueilli de
vaublanc chemin vous pourrez regarder le
genre de cailloux qu'on trouve dans
cette région là vous prenez une carte
géologique ou vous allez sur le site
géoportail est comme ça vous pouvez
aller regarder et ça aide énormément à
réduire le champ de recherche donc
croyez moi c'est une bonne idée et c'est
pas de la triche
voilà donc pour les critères principaux
salaires beaucoup comme ça et il ya
plein de mots barbares qui vous sont
tombés dessus d'un coup mais
rassurez-vous le plus dur est passé
maintenant vous connaissez les règles du
jeu vous allez pouvoir jouer vous même
c'est vraiment plus facile et amusant à
faire que ça en a l'air
sachez que vous n'êtes pas seul dans ce
grand jeu des cailloux il existe plein
de ressources en ligne et des bouquins
pour vous aider et toute une communauté
indique tout ça en description de la
vidéo où vous l'aurez peut-être remarqué
ce que je vous ai présenté là c'est un
peu à la va comme je te pousse mon
soupèse on renifle on taton rayon lèche
mans c'est un peu artisanal tout si je
commence à comprendre la réputation des
jeux c'est pas de notre faute si on
utilise tous nos sens et si on nous tous
vos chakras mais les vraies prouesses
qui font aussi comme ça ils ont à peu
près les mêmes critères que nous densité
dureté éclat système cristallin tous ces
trucs là mais ils ont aussi des outils
plus performants et ils font d'autres
mesures à côté dans des machines et au
microscope comme des mesures de pelé au
cros isme dame isotropique et de bi
réflectance c'est vous qui avez demandé
tout ça ça permet aux minéralogiste
d'aller encore plus loin dans
l'identification de leurs cailloux mais
globalement le principe est le même et
chemin faisant les chercheurs découvrent
parfois des nouveaux minéraux grâce aux
progrès techniques on en découvre même
de plus en plus on a trouvé 150 nouveaux
minéraux en 2018 contre une vingtaine
dans les années 60 car voyez-vous bien
de ces les machines de plus en plus
performantes permettent de repérer même
des minuscules minéraux microscopique en
inclusion à l'intérieur d'autres
minéraux plus grosse et migros et
pionner du coup il n'y a pas besoin
d'aller à l'autre bout du monde pour
trouver d espèce minérale il suffit
parfois juste d'ouvrir les tiroirs des
collections des facs ou des musées et
les analyser pour décrocher le jackpot
sais c'est un peu génial en fait ils
étaient sous notre nez depuis le début
mais on n'avait juste pas les bonnes
lunettes pour les voir en un mot comme
en cent remugles
or donc vous l'aurez compris la corée du
nord n'est pas le régime le plus et
aussi les jo diversité se porte comme un
charme
8/10 géodiversité hui jeudi encore se
porter comme un charme et donc je trouve
ça plus réjouissant de parler de
géodiversité que de biodiversité en ce
moment parce que un c'est sur yann
arthus bertrand et 2 ça change un peu de
découvrir de nouvelles espèces minérale
plutôt que d'en faire disparaître en
mangeant du nutella en faisant des
rondes au volant de notre mort et en
plus si jamais vous trouvez vous un
nouveau minéral et qu'il est reconnu par
la commission internationale qui s'en
occupe lui
ça aussi ça existe vous pourriez en gros
lui donner le nom de votre choix à
condition qu'il soit dispo bien sûr que
soient pas offensant et l' usage veut
qu'on termine le nom par it it
alors comment vous appelleriez votre
minérale à vous quelles seraient ses
caractéristiques dix mois tout ça en
commentaire c'est pour moi référencement
maintenant vous savez tout bon jeu à
vous voilà on fera peut-être quelques
lives twitch d'identification de
minéraux ça pourrait être marrant dit
moi si ça vous même si vous allez très
vite comprendre que je suis à peu près
aussi mauvaise
à ce jeu qui a imité céline dion je vous
ai compris
je voulais pas quand
merci au type heures dont l'éclat
adamantin m'éblouit jour après jour
c'est grâce à votre soutien que tout
ceci est et merci aussi à l'université
de nantes de m'avoir invité à leur nuit
blanche des chercheurs 2021 pour la
diffusion de cette vidéo en avant
première suivie d'un échange en live
avec vous dès que cette vidéo sera
terminée c'est à dire dès que j'aurai
fini cette phrase qui va très bientôt
entrer au livre guinness des records
comme étant la phrase la plus longue du
monde jamais prononcé d'une traite dans
une vidéo de vulgarisation francophone
relatives à l'identification des
minéraux oui la vidéo parler de ça au
fait
[Musique]
merci valentine pour cette vidéo qui
nous donne le sourire et nous a bien
fait rire
merci à tous d'où viennent toutes ces
idées là c'était avec beaucoup
d'imprévus
ça vient de ma tête oui avec pas mal
d'imprévus et puis j'ai des idées qui me
gêne quand j'ai écrit le script et j'ai
des idées qui me viennent aussi en amont
j'ai une liste sur mon ordinateur de
liste d'idées à la con que je crois je
les appelais et puis de temps en temps
quand je cherche l'inspiration je peux
aller puiser dedans
et voilà mais en général c'est des trucs
qui me viennent spontanément quand
j'écris ou alors au tournage voilà ou au
montage aussi ça m'arrive souvent de de
réécrire des passages en échangeant des
morceaux et en rajoutant des blagues
par-dessus remontage parce que parce que
ça me vient sur le moment donc l'imprévu
est bien présent oui beaucoup de
questions justement des internautes qui
ont regardé votre vidéo d'abord quel est
votre rôle préféré valentine amarouche
préférées ça tombe bien parce que j'en
ai pas donc je peux vous en parler mais
je pourrais pas vous la montrer
c'est le alors ça mon minérale préféré
en tout cas c'est le zircon j'ai même
fait une vidéo là dessus qu'ils
s'appellent zircon comme un ballet quand
un truc comme ça
et en fait c'est un petit minérale qu'on
appelle le faux diamants aussi donc ça
ressemble un diamant sauf que c'en est
pas et sa particularité c'est qu'il est
radioactif et que c'est grâce à sa
faible radioactivité qu'on a réussi à
dater la terre qu'on sait maintenant
qu'elle fait enfin call à quatre
milliards et demi d'années et ça je
trouve ça beau et c'est son vrai nom
voilà le vrai nom simon oui c'est son
vrai nom z irc au web
d'accord c'est pas d'humour est il
possible
est il possible qu'un jour nous
découvrions 8e forme de cailloux
ça je serais pas vous dire faudrait
rentrer plus dans les détails de la
physique mais ça fait déjà bien 200 ans
qu'on a qu'on a c'est cette forme donc
ça m'étonnerait mais après alléché enfin
dans les échantillons naturels je pense
pas mais après il ya en crée aussi des
minéraux en laboratoire donc ça pourquoi
pas ce serait possible de trouver un
nouvel assemblage de la matière après je
sais pas je me connais très peu là
dessus
il faudrait poser la question à un vrai
cristallographe ou es ce que vous avez
appris tout ça justement c'est via votre
école tout s'est mis les roues oui c'est
à la fac que j'ai appris ça ça c'est
vraiment les bases que j'ai appris en
cours de minéralogiques j'adorais je
salue mon prof de l'époque vraiment je
gros coup de coeur pour ce cours et puis
après c'est au fil de mes lectures comme
ça à droite à gauche notamment dans les
bouquins que je vais conseiller en
descriptions et hop il ya celui ci qui
me servait à caler mon micro par exemple
donc guide du géologue amateurs il ya
plein de livres qui existent à propos de
la géologie comme quoi ça se vend qu'il
faut croire et ça intéresse d'après
écart tôle les minéraux aussi une sorte
de conscience qu'en pensez vous
valentine ah bah ça tombe très bien
parce que j'ai justement fait une vidéo
là dessus aussi comme sahara et que ses
écrits d'anne ans c'est une vidéo qui
parle d'une théorie en philosophie de
l'esprit qui s'appelle le pan psychisme
donc pente ou et psychisme esprits et
qui dit que l'esprit se rend tout chose
donc dans chaque particule élémentaire
même dans chaque atome tout ça est donc
quelque part les roches aurait une forme
d'esprit même si c'est ces petites
particules d'esprit ne sont pas
rejointes entre elles donc on peut pas
parler d'un vrai esprit comme comme chez
nous par exemple toucher les animaux
donc selon certains philosophes
peut-être éventuellement un petit peu
mais de toute façon cette théorie
philosophique est très très minoritaire
pardon en philosophie de l'esprit et moi
même j'y crois pas des masses
alors si je passe à répondre à votre
question et sa réponse un palais les
faux serait sain et
l'internaute qui remarque ça pouvez vous
nous en dire plus valentine et bien
j'aimerais beaucoup mais j'ai prévu de
faire une vidéo dessus donc je veux pas
trop finalement très sujets sont traités
dans vos vidéos l'asra pu faire il faut
il faudra aller voir sciences de
comptoir si vous découvrirez un jour un
minéral quel nom lui donneriez-vous
palantines j'ai vu passer dans le chatt
quelqu'un qui parlait pédiluve et je
pense que la paix dit lu vite ça
pourrait être bien ce que la valentine
it existe déjà
donc voilà c'est un objet nerd sinon en
hommage à ma soeur je sais pas encore
d'accord à votre soeur fiona c'est ça
oui ma soeur qui m'aident dans les
vidéos aussi on n'en parle pas trop mais
elle et elle est derrière pour suivre
les scripts pour m'aider ou au tournage
elle est très impliquée
vous préférez question imprimés ou
treffel caillou le papier ou le ciseau
valentine a bien sûr le caillou enfin et
voulait les shebab dans certaines vidéos
oui oui oui mais ça encore une fois je
les dis dans la vidéo faut faire
attention de ne pas lécher tout et
n'importe quoi donc quand vous voulez
identifié un caillou n'ayez pas le
premier réflexe de le lécher sais c'est
pas une bonne idée je j'ai reçu des
messages de gens qui me disait est ce
que tu sais ce que c'est comme cailloux
parce que je les lécher ça a pas de goût
spécial et j'étais là mais m'a pas
laissé le tout et n'importe quoi donc
c'est rigolo les géologues fonsat de
temps en temps mais c'est voilà c'est
une cascade de réservé aux
professionnels
j'ai modération à modération selon vous
faut-il avoir fait des études dans le
domaine scientifique que vous vulgariser
ah ça c'est pas une petite question non
bah je dirais que ça aide c'est pas
obligatoire bien sûr parce que même
quand enfin quand j'étais journaliste à
temps plein je pouvais traiter des
sujets que je n'avais pas du tout vu à
l'école
enfin à la fac mais ça aide quand même
surtout quand on est vidéaste parce
qu'en fait ça aide à trouver des sujets
tout simplement cédé des sujets que je
peux me baser sur des petites anecdotes
que j'ai entendue en cour et que et que
je veux approfondir de mon côté donc
ça permet d'avoir une certaine culture
du sujet donc ça c'est pas mal mais
après c'est pas obligatoire et on peut
aussi avoir sa propre culture ans en
lisant des de la presse scientifique ou
en regardant des documentaires ou en
regardant des vidéos youtube ou faire
plein de choses ou des livres on va
parler sur de la culture des médias
justement quels sont les points communs
valentine où les différences entre votre
métier actuel des vidéastes et puis
celui de journaliste que vous avez
pratiqué et que vous pratiquez moins
maintenant c'est quasiment la même chose
enfin surtout en plus en tant que
journaliste j'étais journaliste vidéo
donc cela je vidéaste donc franchement
c'était un peu la même chose simplement
en tant que journaliste j'ai moins
tendance à m'exprimer moi et j'ai plus
tendance à relayer la parole d'autres
gens donc c'est plus des interviews ou
des reportages que là c'est sur youtube
il ya un peu le culte de ousmane sène
soi même on est son propre présentateur
et puis on peut se permettre plus de
blagues de mauvais goût
je pense que même cessé même juste de
l'auto censure mais quand quand on
travaille pour un média on a peut-être
moins tendance à faire des blagues
douteuses
combien de temps valentine ça vous prend
de faire une vidéo c'est très variable
j'imagine c'est extrêmement variable les
dernières
j'ai compté alors celle là j'ai pas du
tout compter mais les dernières ça me
prenait je dire entre 100 et 150 heures
par vidéo ah oui une temps la wii en
comptant tout ce qui est documentation
en amont écriture du script tournage et
montage le montage prend pas mal de
temps aussi pour faire tous les petits
effets idiot quand je mets le visage de
quelqu'un d'autre dans le corps de
quelqu'un d'autre
enfin c'est ça prend pas mal de temps
mais mais ça me fait tellement rigolé
que je vois pas les heures passées et
c'est vous qui fait tout de a à z
oui faites vous encore de la recherche
ou alors vous consacrer uniquement à
votre chaîne sciences de comtois alors
j'ai jamais vraiment fait de recherches
j'ai jamais été chercheuse j'ai fait des
études y compris mon camp je parlais de
biologie ça pour le coup j'ai fait un
master recherche donc dans ce cadre là
j'ai fait des stages
donc ça m'a fait partie enfin ça m'a
permis de voir comment c'était dans un
laboratoire et tout mais j'ai jamais
vraiment été chercheuse donc je suis
vulgarisatrice à temps plein depuis le
début on en voit revenir à votre sujet
les roches sont elles vivantes
on va travailler moi je vais pas je vais
pas répondre puisque je ne sais pas moi
j'y crois pas à ça mais franchement je
sais pas je voulais faire une vidéo là
dessus un peu troll avec en expliquant
un peu tout du long déroulé un espèce de
raisonnement pendant dix minutes un
quart d'heure pour faire croire aux gens
que les roches est évidente
et puis enfin un truc vraiment
convaincant et puis arrivé à la fin des
ans mais non en fait
vous m'avez cru non il faut pas parce
que même la définition du vivant c'est
quand même très particulier
là comme ça je vais plus sous les yeux
donc je vais pas je vais pas improviser
mais déjà même les virus on sait pas si
c'est vivant donc si on pose la question
pour les virus les roches à mon avis il
ya aucune raison qu'ils soient vivants
qu'elle soit vivante
pourquoi de temps choisir un nom en it
alors que on a par exemple le dire qu'on
bat ça c'est une convention mais j'ai
pas spécialement de d'explication là
dessus c'est l' usage en fait it c'est
comme ça qu'on sait le suffixe con mais
pour les proches et parfois pour les
minéraux mais c'est comme ça c'est une
convention je crois pas qu'ils aient
spécialement d'explication là-dessus
faut pas aller chercher trop loin mais
la corvette les premières études en
géologie valentine aulas alors c'est une
discipline qui relativement récente et
quand je dis récente c'est vers darwin
donc c'est quoi ça c'est des 8e 19e
on voit ya quelques siècles voilà et
donc c'est une science qui est
relativement récente il ya eu des
balbutiements mais qui était plus proche
de la religion que de la science et puis
ça finit par n'être au fur et à mesure
donc c'est vraiment une roche qui est
une heure non pas une science qui est
très récente
plus que la biologie et et donc il ya
encore plein plein de choses à découvrir
là dedans
et c'est marrant parce que quand j'ai
quand je me suis documenté en histoire
de la géologie je me suis rendu compte à
quel point cette science intéressante et
à quel point il y avait encore plein de
choses à découvrir et je me suis dit que
si j'avais eu ce genre de cours là quand
j'étais à la fac j'aurais peut-être
continus en recherche en géologie parce
que pour apporter sa pierre à l'édifice
parrot pour le jeune mans mais vraiment
je pense qu'il ya on est on est on je
vais pas dire aux balbutiements parce
que bon ça fait quand même plusieurs
siècles qu'on est dessus mais je pense
qu'il ya encore plein de choses à faire
pour développer la géologie du point de
vue scientifique plein de choses à
découvrir
merci pour ce beau jeux lourd trouve
votre mot à quand remontent les
premières études pendant la jauge les la
géologie peut-elle aider à sauver le
monde
est-ce qu'elle va aider à sauver le
monde je ne saurais pas dire par contre
elle va aider à l aide à prendre du
recul et à réaliser enfin à être plus
humble parce que quand on regarde
l'échelle des temps géologiques
on se rend compte qu'en fait on est peu
de chose à l'échelle de la vie de la
planète et qu'elle se souviendra
probablement jamais de nous de toute
façon et ça permet vraiment de prendre
du recul sur beaucoup de choses
même ce que ce que plusieurs annonces
comme étant l'anthropocène donc on
serait soi-disant dans une époque
géologique
guidés par l'homme et la destruction de
la planète et tout on se rend compte
qu'en fait à l'échelle de la planète ça
risque pas d'être une époque ni même une
r6 serait juste un événement ponctuel
hop là qu'a eu l'homme il a fait des
bêtises et ça un peu déréglé le truc
mais très vite on va passer à autre
chose quoi donc je pense pas que la
géologie permettent de sauver le monde
mais par contre elle permet de prendre
du recul
on va revenir à ce terme de vivant mais
à propos cette fois du corail est ce que
pour vous valentine c'est une roche ou
un être vivant à c'est très intéressant
ça c'est les deux à la fois
en fait c'est un organisme vivant qui
construit un squelette calcaire donc un
caillou et au fur et à mesure il fait
des couches comme ça et donc chaque
organisme vivant construit fin chaque
colonie se construit sur une pile une
montagne de cadavres de ses ancêtres
donc au final c'est un peu des deux cci
par intéressant corey comme ça on va
parler de cailloux quand même c'est
votre
si j'ai trés l'élection justement une
question quel est le caillou le plus
goûtu est le plus mauvais en goût on
précise que c'est à goûter avec
modération vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure a ralenti sa base pense que le
plus goûtu ça doit être le seul
c'est ce qu'on appelle là à liszt et le
sel gemme donc le sel qu'on sort de
terre et qui se forme par évaporation de
grandes étendues d'eau donc vous
imaginez par exemple la méditerranée si
elle s'évapore d'un coup parce qu'il se
met à faire très chaud et bien ça vous
fait une couche de sel au fond et puis
par dessus il peut y avoir d'autres
choses qui vont se déposer d'autres
dépôts sédimentaires ou d'autres genres
et puis on va retrouver après si on si
on creuse on va retrouver ce sel on peut
miner du sel donc ça c'est de la qualité
et à mon avis c'est le caillou le plus
goûtu qu'on pourrait trouver sinon le
moindre bout tu je ne saurais pas vous
dire j'ai pas spécialement été essayé il
paraît que la cellulite et franchement
dégueu mais j'ai jamais eu la chance de
goûter à ça c'est le truc un peu sales
emea mer en même temps et puis après il
doit y avoir des trucs mortel qui
doivent pas être très grands vins très
très goûtu en plus d'être un petit peu
dangereux oui donc il faut pas te goûter
non je pense que le soufre natif ça doit
pas être cool à goûter et je vous
encourage pas à le faire
le machin jaune qu'on voit c'est sûr
elle a souvent dans les dates souvent
dans les collections de pour enfants
donc je ne sais pas quel point c'est
dangereux ou pas mais j'irai pas essayer
rien qu'à la couleur on se dit qu'il ya
un truc pas net
que pensez-vous des boutiques ésotérique
qui vendent des pierres pour les
bienfaits hai ba je pense que je suis un
peu embêté parce que quand on fait des
recherches sur internet pour
s'intéresser aux minéraux safa gossip
complètement toutes les toutes les
réponses
et donc si on n'a pas un minimum de
culture scientifique là dessus on peut
vite se laisser avoir
et après ça fait croire les gens
pourquoi pas mais après cela il la
question est aussi de vous vient je
parle même plus français tellement ça me
perturbe mais je retiens pas déçu mais
on a le temps oui pardon c'est s'énerve
d'où viennent ces minéraux qui vendent
parce que il ya toute une culture de
comment on cultive enfin comment on
extrait ces minéraux là d'où ils
viennent qui les extraits il me semble
qu'il ya pas mal de petits enfants qui
sont utilisées pour extraire ce genre de
truc en afrique vers le bas je crois
enfin voila je pense qu'il ya plein de
choses à creuser sur ce sujet-là jeu
j'aimerais bien faire carrément un
documentaire là dessus un jour s'il faut
parce que là bas une vidéo biarriz
minéraux life non pas une vidéo de 15
minutes
un vrai truc creusé avec beaucoup
d'heures de travail
y at il des passerelles entre les
métiers de vulgarisatrice et celui de
chercheuse passerait dans le sens on
pourrait devenir l'un ou l'autre bas
pour être chercheur il faut c'est une
condition nécessaire mais pas suffisante
avoir une thèse donc un doctorat donc ça
c'est un type de diplôme qui se décroche
en trois quatre ans en sciences en
général sciences dures après si vous
partez du côté des sciences humaines et
sociales ça peut durer beaucoup plus
longtemps et donc à partir du moment où
vous avez ce diplôme là vous pouvez
prétendre à un poste de chercheur il me
semble même si vous avez encore beaucoup
d'années d'études d'errance enfin pas
d'étude mais d'errance dans des
laboratoires à avoir des petits contrats
dès qu'on appelle des post doc post
doctorants post doctorat je sais
post-doc quoi donc c'est pas parce que
vous êtes vulgarisateur que ça vous
donne un privilège là dessus il faudra
de toute façon passer par la tête et par
contre dans l'autre sens ça marche pas
mal parce que les chercheurs ont une
culture incroyable sur leur sujet et
parfois sur d'autres sujets autour et
c'est hyper bien quand ils se mettent à
vulgariser enfin pas forcément au tout
le monde est doué pour ça mais c'est
quand même très utile de bah justement
d'ouvrir la porte du public au
laboratoire et d'aller d'aller voir tout
ça il ya des très bons chercheurs qui
vulgarise super bien et ça c'est bien et
en plus je rappelle que c'est dans les
dents le coûtera quand vous êtes
chercheur il ya une partie médiation une
partie ouverture de votre savoir au
public et qui n'oubliait pas comment les
minéraux font-ils fonctionner nos
portables
valentine
ouh là oui c'est une question un prêt
c'est le casse alors 7 en paille ça
commence les enfants ça commence par des
petits enfants en afrique ou en asie
j'ai fait chi minh tous et puis après ça
finit dans nos télés votre nom je ne
sais pas je connais pas le détail de
l'histoire
mais je crois savoir qu'il ya beaucoup
de terres rares dans nos téléphones
alors c'est une certaine partie de faim
c'est une certaine catégorie de
d'éléments chimiques qui sont dans nos
téléphones et il ya des batailles pour
les avoir je ne saurais pas trop vous
dire mais je crois que en plus ils sont
pas mal
enfin il y en a pas mal aussi au fond
des océans et des terres rares au niveau
des zones hydrothermales vous savez les
fumeurs noirs les fumeurs blanc tout ça
donc c'est des zones qui sont
particulièrement d'intérêt pour pour les
entreprises qui font des trucs de
nouvelles technologies et compagnie on
va passer ce qu'on s'appelle we hope
on va passer à un autre sujet sur les
autres disciplines quels sont les autres
disciplines que qui peuvent collaborer
avec la géologie
oh la la merci pour cette question il y
en a plein
c'est c'est pour ça que j'adore la
géologie sait que c'est sa touche
vraiment à tout aussi bien là pardon je
m'emballe encore à les îles à la
biologie ça ya énormément de pont entre
la géologie la biologie on peut aller du
côté du climat aussi tous cas
climatologie météorologie on peut aller
physique bien évidemment la physique la
chimie
ça touche un peu tous un même du côté de
l'économie quand je vous disais
l'économie des terres rares tout ça on
en parle en très très mal eh ben ça
touche aussi l'économie ça touche aussi
tous questions sociales pour savoir d'où
viennent les minerais et comment ils
sont utilisés ce genre de choses dans
quel pays aussi enfin il ya plein de
choses à faire et ça touche vraiment à
tous donc c'est ça qui est fantastique
et les maths aussi bien évidemment c'est
pour ça que vous aimez faire vos vidéos
qui touchent à tous en fête et avoir une
diversité des sujets
exactement pourquoi les atomes anthisnes
d'une maille adoptent t-il une structure
cristalline précise et pas une autre
quel phénomène entre jeu dans la
formation de la maille
voyez ces questions avec les différentes
les unes des autres et on remercie les
internautes qui sont très nombreux ce
soir à se connecter et à poser des
questions merci merci pour toutes vos
questions sauf celle-là non mais là vous
allez vous rendre compte que j'ai pas
s'est creusée mon sujet ça tient à la à
la chimie la physique en fait de voir
comment les atomes s'organise et mais je
ne serai pas les plus en détail que ça
mais non je ne préfère pas m'engager
là-dessus désolé je peux faire des
recherches et puis revenir là-dessus
peut-être sur twitter si vous me posez
la question je pourrais essayer de
trouver des réponses et vous répondre là
dessus je suis désolé et pourquoi pas
faire plus tard une vidéo là dessus on
verra pour que pensez-vous de la
lithothérapie valentine la lithothérapie
je pense qu'il ya rien de
scientifiquement prouvé il ya eu
quelques chercheurs qui sont qui sont
pencher là dessus qu'on fait des
expériences et qui ont trouvé que la
lithothérapie n'était pas plus efficace
qu'un placebo
donc qu'on vous donne un vrai minérale
ou une ventouse de cabinet dans la main
si on à partir du moment où vous dit ça
va vous guérir
vous pouvez ressentir les mêmes effets
que ce soit l'un ou l'autre
donc voilà d'accord c'est prouvé chez
marc est la menace est étonnant
oui oui bah écoutez après il reste aux
enfin gajo lithothérapeute de nous
prouver que ça marche mieux que le
placebo quoi d'accord et c'est prouvé
enfin oui c'est une sensation qu'on a
c'est inconscient du coup peut-être
c'est un phénomène psychologique wii qui
s'appelle le placebo et qu'il ya aussi
l'effet placebo y en a aussi quand vous
prenez un médicament il ya une partie de
sa qui de l'effet du médicament qui
vient juste du fait de vous physiquement
prendre un médicament et vous vous dites
déjà j'ai pris un truc ça ça va aller
mieux l'accès est purement psychologique
mais après c'est bien il faut savoir
exploiter les faits placebo dans la dent
les guérisons je sais pas combien on va
parler toujours de gueye non c'est
l'anti miel pierre utilisez-vous pour
éviter enfin utiliseriez-vous pour
éviter les malaises à bien je prends
sachant qu'on a dit tout ce qu'on a dit
avant je pense qu'il faut prendre des
tourmaline taillé en pointe et pas
oublier de les recharger aussi à la à la
pleine lune ça c'est très important
il yal urines de caribou à la corse est
votre recette miracle oui et d'ailleurs
je vais ouvrir ma boutique en ligne de
lithothérapie donc n'hésitez pas à
retrouver sur ma chaîne tous les liens
et vous allez vendre quoi alors
exactement à bas des cailloux bien sûr
plein de cailloux
puis je vais devenir riche comme ça
abbas et des cailloux qui guérissent
tout même le covin d'accord mais et des
caillons qu'on pourra acheter sur et qui
nous feront des bienfaits cinéma la
nationale à
on va pas s'en méfier ok exactement
effet placebo garantie sauf si ça marche
pas
quels seront vos prochaines
collaborations sur youtube
aa suspect secret où vous pouvez voir ce
soit je peux vous parler d'une série
qu'on a fait avec le vortex donc ça
c'est une chaîne youtube qui est
coproduite par arte et donc là on vient
de sortir de la saison 3 à laquelle j'ai
participé aussi et là il va commencer à
y avoir la saison 4 de diffuser je crois
que c'est le 17 février donc là pouf
pouf qu'on a tourné l'été dernier et
c'est la saison des thèmes que
le principe du vortex pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est un mélange de
vulgarisation et de fiction donc ça fait
un peu comment dire hélène et les
garçons mais version scientifique bac +
92 et pardon s'il ya des gens de voir
texte qui me regardent
mais non c'était très amusant à filmer
et du coup ce sera à publier tous les
quinze jours je crois une nouvelle vidéo
sur la chaîne youtube du vortex à
laquelle j'ai participé
enfin cette saison et en moyenne sur
science du comtois vous publiez combien
de vidéo ces irréguliers ou c'est chaque
set vous astreignez a publié une vidéo
puisque 550 heures c'est quand même
beaucoup
oui c'est extrêmement irrégulier en fait
je fais en fonction du temps que j'ai et
puis ça dépend de mon organisation aussi
je peux commencer à travailler sur
plusieurs vidéos en parallèle et puis
les sortir au fur et à mesure et puis
après il peut avoir une pause de deux
mois comme la met donc c'est très
variable je suis une très mauvaise élève
pour ça et quels sont vos prochains
projets valentine or youtube est ce que
vous en avez d'autres
alors j'ai d'autres projets
essentiellement dormir ça peut être bien
mais j'ai d'autres projets dans les
tiroirs mais là pour le coup je peux pas
vous en parler malheureusement mais
restez branchés et ont branché sur
science du comptoir et puis vous avez
envie d'ouvrir une boutique sur tout et
si c'est ça on aura tout à fait ce sera
une franchise y en aura dans le monde
entier
vente en ligne tout ça n'aurait été rien
qu'est ce qui vous anime quand vous
réalisez ces vidéos c'est de de ferran
donner envie de s'intéresser à la
géologie
également aussi de dans le fond de rire
c'est l'appât du gain essentiellement
sait tous vous êtes vous bien sûr c'est
la ligue 1 comme on dit ce qui le
caractérise
exactement d'ailleurs je suis payé par
youtube et par jean michel blanc car
pour sortir ces vidéos là et par big
pharma non sinon plus sérieusement mon
idée à la base c'était de de vulgariser
un d'un domaine qui était complètement
négligé depuis le début enfin pas
complètement complètement mais disons
que ceux qui parlaient un peu de ça sur
youtube
c'était surtout des paléontologues et il
n'y avait pas vraiment de chaînes
dédiées à la géologie elle même pas que
je sache en tout cas et donc ça ça
m'intéressait et surtout ça m'intéresse
c'est d'essayer de changer l'image de la
géologie dans la tête du grand public
est un peu des scientifiques aussi
qu'ils considèrent un peu ça comme une
sous discipline qui sert un peu à rien
des gens qui jusqu'il synthés qui lèche
des cailloux au bord dans les faits je
fais des vidéos qui expliquent sa mais
l'idée c'est de montrer qu'il ya un peu
autre chose derrière et que ça peut être
rigolo et qu'on n'est pas tout seul des
gens avec des espèces de gilet avec
plein de poches partout qui vont sur le
terrain et qui font devant un
affleurement quoi y'a du y voit que ça
merci beaucoup valentine merci aussi à
vous d'avoir posé autant de questions et
n'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour sur
la chaîne youtube donc chances de
comptoir on va parler maintenant de deux
conférences sur la proche du haut à
l'ère numérique en fait si le monde des
arts et de la science se rencontrent
c'est avec force qu'il décloisonne les
disciplines et les savoirs pour ouvrir
le champ de tous les possibles
ce format nous vous inédit de
conférences art et science permet de
faire entrer en dialogue des approches
de recherche artistique et scientifique
pour explorer les convergences et les
écarts entre un processus de création
artistique friande imprévus ou au
contraire la volonté d'anticiper un cet
imprévu pour répondre à des exigences
scientifiques
alors ici prendra tout son sens eh bien
le partenariat entre stereolux et
l'université nantes
à suivre donc deux conférences entre
chercheurs de l'université de nantes et
artistes et n'oubliez pas le concept de
cette nuit blanche des chercheurs elle
est interactif donc n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions alors on va
retrouver dans quelques instants donc
pour les accueillir sur scène damien
eveillard et puis je vais remercier ms
dos d'être en direct depuis la corée du
sud depuis séoul avec nous et pensez à
poser toutes vos questions
allez je me lève pour accueillir damien
eveillard bonsoir damien merci d'être
avec moi sur scène
et puis bon soir ms dos vous vous êtes
en duplex depuis séoul où vous
travaillez pour la biennale c'est ça
hein gwangju exactement alors merci à
tous les deux comment l'imprévu a été
intégré dans vos travaux de recherche et
où cela vous at-il emmené d'abord damien
l'imprévu
l'imprévu déjà parlé finition on
l'attend pas et donc en fait moi mes
recherches ça concerne la modélisation
des systèmes vivants et donc quand on
les systèmes vivants sont par définition
très imprévus et quand j'essaye de les
modéliser j'utilise des approches
informatique et là on essaie d'enlever
l'imprévu on essaye de les lags et on
essaye d'avoir les idées les plus clair
possible
donc ça m'a amené finalement le cet
imprévu le manipuler tous les jours mais
en même temps ce qui a été déjà dit
aussi dans les conférences précédentes
c'est un peu le sel de tout ça c'est à
dire que c'est ce qui nous motive cet
imprévu on va chercher à le comprendre
donc informatiquement on va chercher à
le transposer dans des dents des
abstractions informatique
c'est à dire que si c'est trop compliqué
si ces trois prévus c'est peut-être
qu'on s'est trompé dans la manière de le
représenter
donc aurait cherché à le représenter de
manière un peu différente une fois qu'on
y est représenté de manière votre
guillemets cohérente informatiquement
bon on va essayer de voir si on avait
tort si on découvre des nouvelles
hypothèses si bas on a découvert des
nouvelles choses et donc si je donne un
exemple parce que là c'est un peu
philosophique c'est par exemple essayer
de comprendre comment le dgen qu'on
pourrait retrouver dans des bactéries
pourraient avoir un impact sur le climat
donc là on est sûr de l'imprévu c'est à
dire qu'on pourrait avoir quasiment ce
qu'on attend avec le battement d'aile du
papillon qui créerait des ouragans
là on a certains gènes chez certaines
bactéries marines notamment qu'ils vont
nous permettre de respirer kivu différé
le climat donc c'est essayer de
d'encapsuler tout ça dans un dans un
cadre un peu près formelle donc on
essaye d'élaguer cet imprévu mais au
départ on est stimulée par cet imprévu
et vous aimez dos comment justement
l'imprévu fait partie de vos travaux et
où est-ce qui vous a emmené après vu
arriver au moment où j'ai commencé à
travailler que les ordinateurs et l'idée
de pouvoir créer ses pattes erdre
ethnique soi même à partir de là je
trouvais vachement intéressant que pas
de casser le systématisme en fait du
rythme et de rentrer dans quelque chose
de pur randomisés donc du coup le mot
random dans la musique électronique est
très présent donc je pourrais dire que
voilà c'est ça fait partie du folklore
de la musique électronique comme
expérimentale est donc totalement
embrasé et comment se retrouve on
retrouve dans le système du vivant et
qu'est ce qu'on peut en faire pour vos
disciplines respectives
d'accord je commence à les y revient
donc dans un système vivant on peut là
on peut l'aborder de plusieurs manières
dont il ya des des gens qu'ils attaquent
pour un système de santé est ce que le
vivant c'est la santé d'un point de vue
un peu plus théorique qu'on peut
attaquer le vivent donc on va dire de
manière un peu mécanistiques qu'on va
essayer de décortiquer toutes les
briques de lego comment les briques de
lego vont sans beauté les unes avec les
autres
nous dans le laboratoire la manière dont
on perçoit le vivant c'est plutôt on va
essayer de délimiter les bornes c'est à
dire que on sait que le vivant on va pas
être capable de l'appréhender de manière
très fine de manière tout le temps
précise ont par contre on sait que si on
meurt on va pas revenir à la vie on sait
que on va en général de respirer de
l'oxygène on sait en général qu'on va
utiliser telle mosquée telles molécules
pour survivre donc en fait on va poser
des bornes et en fait on en définissant
ces bornes on va mettre en place un
espèce d espace dans lequel après on va
essayer de raisonner on va essayer de
comprendre les choses
et cet espace ça nous permet d'intégrer
l'incertitude pour revenir un peu sur la
notion d'un prévu donc d'intégrer cette
incertitude et puis ça permet aussi de
laisser les systèmes un plus bouger un
peu vivre et voir comment les systèmes
ans adapté la résilience des systèmes
donc peut-être que là il ya des
connexions si avec eux enfin avec
kenneth dose parce que quelque part il
ya des patterns qu'on va essayer de
retrouver ces pattern ils sont issus de
bruit mais finalement ses patins sont à
l'intérieur de cet espace qu'on essaye
de réduire et finalement les recherches
ça va consister à rajouter à chaque fois
des nouvelles frontières qui vont
peut-être permettre de réduire au
maximum cet espace qui peut paraître
abstrait encore une fois mais qui
mathématiquement a du sens et qui nous
permet d'avoir des outils pour
pour étudier cet espace de manière à peu
près rigoureuse vous partager le point
de vue de dames hier justement
aujourd'hui j'aurais carrément oui c'est
totalement mais les deux ans dans ma
pratique le vivant c'est parle d'art
vivant justement donc c'est à dire que
c'est omniprésent dans la pratique
alors ça soit dans le travail
chorégraphique mais moi ce qui est
marrant c'est que je dirais que j'ai
j'ai travaillé avec une autre sorte de
vivant en fait le fait de m'intéresser
aux insectes aux bactéries se fait avec
des vivants qui ne dialogue pas avec moi
donc c'était c'est là où justement il
convient dans l'imprévu justement dans
le round up savent quelque chose que je
maîtrise pas on n'a pas un langage
commun et du coup je voudrais essayer
d'établir un protocole voir justement
établir d'aidé systématisme en fait et
c'est là où moi je serais vraiment le
vivant était totalement transposé sur
autre chose mais dans le rapport entre
le public et l'artiste il ya aussi
quelque chose qui est assez intéressant
et qui est aussi dans l'ordre du hasard
on peut pas savoir si quelqu'un aime ce
qu'on fait ou pas s'il n'y a pas des
petites rigueur qui nous permet de
pouvoir dialoguer avec donc ça c'est ça
c'est marrant en fait on se retrouve
dans les mêmes
ouais
et si je peux rebondir il ya aussi une
motivation différente c'est que le
vivant ça peut être source de nouvelles
théories c'est à dire que parce qu'on
reste bloquée parce que des fois on est
bloqué et finalement il ya aussi une
perception différente qui va arriver et
qui fait qu on s'était peut-être
fourvoyé donc je passe je pense
notamment aux quand on s'attaque à un
système yvan pion ont prédit des trucs
très très faim et puis finalement on se
rend compte qu'il ya une donnée qui
arrive qui fait que bah ça marche plus
quoi et si ça marche plus ça veut dire
qu'il faut peut-être trop changé la
manière dont on m'avait posé les
questions donc revenir au départ est
donc le vivant va stimuler les méthodes
aussi c'est à dire qu'une méthode qui
marche est elle ne va plus marcher
et ça veut pas dire qu'il faut tout
casser ça veut dire qu'on va peut être
se réinventer et retrouver des choses et
ce feedback
c'est aussi c'est un feedback vivent
quelque part aussi parce que c'est ça
qui fait la recherche est donc là la
beauté de l'informatique qu'on a quand
on étudie le système avancé qu' on a une
palette énorme de
de formalisation on peut représenter les
systèmes vivants comme des dessins comme
des cartes comme des objets qui vont
bouger avec des probabilités avec des
choses qui vont qui vont complètement
changer et à chaque fois qu'on découvre
quelque chose de nouveau parce qu'on est
stimulé vous êtes des fois même par les
biologistes qui ont leur perception des
choses
basso nous oblige peut-être à reposer un
peu proprement et et développer des
nouvelles des nouvelles méthodes et est
ce que ce que tu dis c'est un peu ça
c'est que aussi on a on a besoin de
faire un feedback un peu en temps réel
et c'est ça que c'est qu'il ya du vivant
de biologie mais aussi le vivant de la
vie de chercheur et donc ça vous oblige
finalement avancé n'ont pas reculé
des fois vous pour quoi que ce soit si
linéaire que sa lancée c'est très
incertain
ça serait trop facile ouais on serait
déjà on voit si on savait déjà la
direction
je pense que c'est parce que c'est ça
aussi c'est accepter aussi de balai dans
une direction enfin oui c'est ce que
j'attends avec ça c'est que ça me tombe
on parle donc pas être le système
linéaire mais moi ce que j'adore c'est
que ouais ça me renvoie donc plein de
coordonner en fait et j'attends ce
moment où je vais atterrir et je suis
assez content chaque fois de savoir que
vous la terre quelque part en tout cas
mais je ne cherche pas un résultat avec
ce genre de recherche ns2 quels sont les
outils comment vous vos outils vous ont
amené à vous intéresser justement aux
vivants et comment les mettez vous à
disposition de vos travaux au début faut
savoir moi j'ai un génie j'ai un
background de danseurs donc à un moment
donné dans d'antan dans mes études j'ai
voulu travailler sur la danse et des
nouvelles technologies donc ça m'a
emmené à sortir de mon corps en fait
rentrer un peu plus dans des choses un
peu plus théoriques et travail que des
machines et aux furieux que mes études
bah je me suis rendu compte que voilà
ces outils là était intéressant pour
gérer pour faire du canevas en fait pour
s'inspirer de ces machines là et puis
leur travail dans des systèmes
chorégraphique est maintenant en fait
j'ai constitue une palette d'outils que
j'utilisais qui me permette justement
d'être très précis dans ce qui est bio
feedback et ce genre de choses mais
aussi le travail algorithmique
le coding genre de chose qui permette de
sortir des protocoles intéressant pour
des concepts de performance ou ce genre
de choses ns2 vous êtes un artiste qui
touche à tout vous êtes à la fois
musicien hackers performeur chorégraphe
donc l'art dans toute sa splendeur
ouais ouais mais après ce qu'est ce qui
est marrant c'est que c'est toujours
rattaché au mouvement et moi pour moi
c'est que toutes les disciplines que je
touchais l'ont toujours sont toujours
liés avec le mouvement fait un je ne
sais pas s'il ya un mot pour cette
discipline
mais voilà je suis je suis amoureux du
mouvement à n'importe quelle échelle que
ce soit et quel est votre lien avec la
science je dirais que ça c'est un c
ç'a toujours été inspirant parce que
quand on travaille avec les technologies
forcément entre avec la science en fait
c'est toujours des avancées
scientifiques qui permettent de pouvoir
développer des outils que à la suite moi
je me réapproprie donc agir qui a
toujours ce truc que j'ai toujours gardé
la science comme une espèce de 2,2
d'inspiration entre autres parmi
d'autres inspirations mais voilà une
inspiration c'est très profond et vous
quel est votre lien finalement
inversement avec la navy en préparant
cette conférence que l'artiste et
scientifique et dans le fond avec
quelques points communs parce que le
scientifique au départ quand il commence
une recherche et ben c'est comme un
artiste quand il part d'un délire sauf
qu'après la différence d'un artiste il
faut qu'il le démontre il faut que il le
prouve
mais du coup je me demande si c'est pas
la même démarche
parce que j'imagine que quand on est
artiste on a une extrême rigueur aussi
c'est à dire qu'on a une idée en tête et
on veut absolument y arriver donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi casser des vo
technique va d'ailleurs ça me permet de
rebondir peut-être pour poser une
question c'est quand tu quand tu
développes des nouveaux programmes
est-ce que tu pars de rien ou est-ce que
tu t'inspires de ski pin en fait
l'étincelle initial pour dire enfin je
vais prendre la question par rapport à
l'informatique notamment tu parlais de
deux programmes et d'algorithmes de
choses comme ça la motivation initiale
est ce qu'elle vient d'une
dada comment dire d'un but à long terme
donc tu sais déjà vers quoi tu vas où
est-ce que c'est l'opportunité de
d'apprendre des choses qui fait que de
proche en proche tu avances enfin c'est
là où je peux me permettre de poser
cette question ça m'intéresse vraiment
basse et laisser les deux en fait savent
que par exemple ce qui est drôle c'est
que depuis tout petit j'ai toujours eu
le but d'être un espèce de danseurs
augmenté donc savoir faire du mouvement
mais à côté de ça pouvoir gérer la
lumière dialogue avec des machines genre
de choses et ça m'a emmené bas vous
parler aujourd'hui ce soir parce qu'ea
c'est assez drôle sauf que j'aurais
jamais pensé à un moment donné que ces
disciplines de biofeedback allait être
quelque chose de très important pour moi
dans ma dans la vie d'artiste en fait
donc voilà lci pour moi y'a un peu les
deux trucs quoi sortie à ce but commun
de pouvoir grâce aux mouvements révélé
plein de concepts sort des aussi des
concepts scientifiques mathématiques lui
et autres et à côté de ça voilà il ya
les rencontres qui m'enrichit absolument
et qui font de moins en fait quelqu'un
d'heureux en fait quelqu'un qui a envie
de chercher de plus c'est quelqu'un qui
a envie de voile à 2-2 d'extraire ça
pour faire de la poésie avec donc voilà
c'est pour moi c'est vraiment les deux
et donc je pense qu on se rejoint quand
même vraiment sur plein de choses
après la poésie je ne suis pas sûr pour
la science mais en tout cas il est si
les rencontres enfin on en parle aussi
souvent c'est à dire que parce qu'on va
rencontrer un chercheur priori qu'on
n'aurait pas imaginé on va se retrouver
à discuter et à être confronté avec des
idées des nouvelles manières de penser
et ça permet d'appréhender les choses et
notamment la biologie c'est un domaine
qui est tellement vaste c'est une
discipline où enfin sur garde chez dans
dans les sciences il ya plein ce qu'on
appelle deux sections de deux
scientifiques qui se disent tous
biologiste ça va débuter généticiens
biologistes moléculaires écologistes
enfin de me les socios là quelque part
un peu de la biologie aussi et c'est
fascinant à chaque fois qu'on rencontre
sigean c'est une interdisciplinarité
c'est une émulsion qui arrive à émerger
je pense que c'est quasiment la même
motivation quand on est artiste
après je dis pas qu'on va jusqu'à la
poésie mais si je peux me permettre
quand on veut comprendre comment un
système marché une fois qu'on l'a
compris c'est un peu de la poésie aussi
c'était là qu'on peut peut-être a
conseillé raconter avec des mots simples
un truc qui est très compliqué et
paradoxalement la simplicité c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus dur à faire c'est à
dire
et une fois qu'on a un truc ça paraît
tellement clair c'est les gens se disent
mais pourquoi pourquoi j'ai pas pensé
avant
et je pense que c'est la même chose de
fou avec les musiques à des morceaux de
musique ou des cons les annonces d'ubs à
ces jeux c'est comme si on connaissait
déjà parce que ça prend la tête et c
c'est vivant et on la cua et je pense
que de ce côté là la science et l'art
c'est un peu la même chose c'est
abstrait mais on arrive on essaye d'en
faire quelque chose qui a du sens pour
tout le monde et je pense que c'est à
peu près là on ce retour un peu un ouais
ouais carrément mais sachant qu'en plus
il se dissipa donc ces disciplines
nouvelles qui sont arrivés avec tout ce
qui était justement se dit fication
données genre de choses qui ont en même
temps je pense vachement rapprocher les
artistes des scientifiques et surtout 4
et des nouvelles vocations de
scientifiques qui se sont exprimés
artistiquement aussi est un et ça je
trouve ça vachement est franchement
intéressant ces espèces de métissage
d'hybridation de deux disciplines comme
ça qui bat qui font émerger des nouveaux
des nouveaux mouvements en fait et
aujourd'hui mais non par boudar science
c'est pas pour rien en fait c'est qu'un
un moment dévoile à des convergences au
niveau des intérêts et aussi de ce qu'on
trouve le bo en fait ce que veut dire le
beau dans la science et à quel moment le
beau dans la science devient le bout
dans l'art aussi vous vous comment s'est
passée votre rencontre justement c'était
improbable
en fait on sait jamais rencontré
vraiment enfin on s'est rencontrés via
des avatars ce que je disais à la
dernière réunion si je suis même pas sûr
qu'il existe vraiment pas ce que j'ai vu
à l'écran titre est extrait qui m'a gêné
ce dos derrière on m'a dit tu vas parler
kenneth dos mais je n'ai jamais trompé
et
et en fait danser le sait la nuit
blanche des chercheurs qui ont fait
qu'on s'est rencontrés c'est juste une
super opportunité après ça serait bien
qu'on je sais pas moi j'ai envie d'en
savoir plus info j'ai envie de gérer
envie de hacker le hacker pour savoir
comment tu penses certaines choses
c'est je peux pas vendre inspiré mais
bon voilà quelques questions justement
vous bah en fait là il ya une question
moi qui me fascine chez les artistes
c'est le sait la manière dont ils
appréhendent le vivant c'est à dire
enfin c'est un peu 107 ma science c'est
ce qu'on essaye de faire en
collaboration avec plein de gens avec
plein de disciplines scientifiques
mais est ce que je vous dis c'est que
des fois on a peut-être derrière parce
que académiquement on pense les choses
d'une certaine manière on est quelque
part on va dire ces derniers temps on a
un peu plus de créativité parce qu'on ne
voit plus les choses
c'est à dire que la biologie avant on va
dire je voyais un insecte
je sais que c'est un insecte et on
comprend on fait des tests j'enlève les
ailes de l'insecte je jette un peu
caricatural il vole plus mais elles
servent à 2 a volé enfin voila c je
caricature mais aujourd'hui en fait on
travaille sur des objets en biologie
qu'on ne voit pas enfin les jeunes c'est
des choses qui sont complètement
abstrait et jamais personne n'a vu un
gène on voit le résultat de gênes
on voit on voit des choses qui sont la
résultante d'objets qu'on imagine réel
mais en fait on les voit plus et ce qui
fait que ça nous débris d'un peu notre
manière de penser et on raisonne de plus
en plus sur des abstractions sur des
choses qui sont pas qu'on ne peut pas
toucher et sur des systèmes de proba des
fois c'est là des fois c'est pas là mais
c'est pas grave on arrive quand même à
trouver des règles et je pense que les
artistes
enfin et je pense que toi tu étais au
milieu de tout ça je j'ai l'impression
que tu as une vision qui était propre
bah ce que c'est que le vivant à des
quand tu parles on a l'impression que tu
as compris beaucoup de choses et en fait
je serais curieux de savoir et d'échangé
par rapport à ça pour savoir si on peut
pas s'inspirer
est-ce que notamment la forme la danse
le mouvement c'est des choses qu'on a du
mal à appréhender le mouvement c'est ce
qui est plus dure à appréhender dans
dans les analyses du vivant c'est à dire
qu'on paradoxalement on voit les
évolutions des choses c'est ça qui nous
permet de comprendre mais en même temps
si on répète trop on se rend compte
qu'on n'a pas si bien compris donc c'est
un peu la boîte de pandore on n'a pas
toujours envie de voir se répéter tant
que ça
et en même temps ça coûte très cher donc
en fait on fait avec ce qu'on a et on
aimerait bien en faire plus mais donc la
vision du mouvement de la dynamique du
fait d'avoir des patterns qui vont
ressortir d'antan des dents des sont
peut-être des choses qui reviennent
comme étant des des choses qui émerge de
choses qui peuvent paraître hyper
brouillonne de prime abord mais qui fait
qu' on retrouve des choses qui semblent
avec un rythme des choses comme ça c'est
des choses qui m'a me fascine mais parce
que après je parle beaucoup peut-être
mais j'ai la vision que les systèmes
vivants sont des systèmes enfin je suis
pas le seul mais 10 des systèmes un peu
organisés on sait pas pourquoi c'est là
mais en tout cas il ya une résultante
qui fait que la résultante c'est que le
vivant est là l'individu est là le
biologique et là la terre est là et
c'est la résultante de beaucoup de
choses qui dépendent du mouvement de la
cinétique des attractions des pelé
probabilité éventuellement et je pense
que c'est des choses que les artistes
ont déjà appréhendé
de quelles que soient les arts que ce
soit même en sculpture le son la musique
et la danse passé s'est fait partie des
choses où on cherche à chaque fois à
casser des choses qui sont trop ri trop
trop rigoureuse et savoir voilà je
m'emporte un peu mais c'est ça que
j'aimerais bien quand je disais tout à
l'heure j'ai envie de te à quai c'est ça
c'est j'aimerais bien avoir une
inspiration par rapport à ça et voir si
on peut pas peut-être voir autrement les
choses avaient peut-être que de trouver
une inspiration auprès d'artistes non
moi je suis complètement hackers
friendly baisse également ça en plus ce
qui est drôle c'est que et encore
aujourd'hui en dans la danse je l'essaie
de casser encore les codes qui sont déjà
très très présent en fait je pense que
c'est très récent en fait aussi dans
l'art vivant de vouloir travailler dans
ce qui est un peu plus chaotique en fait
parce que pendant longtemps en fait
c'est plus qu'à vous n'étiez pas quelque
chose qui était très très me rends au
pied près mis en avant aujourd'hui on en
parle un peu plus la france un peu plus
séduisant comme mots parce que
finalement ça ouvre à plein de choses à
ou à se dire finalement je pense
philosophiquement parlant que le monde
n'est pas rigide et qu'on peut encore
changer des choses et qui peut avoir des
choses émergentes qui peuvent apparaître
et avoir des changements de paradigmes
soir à n'importe quel est chef de la
société mais je veux dire il ya quelque
chose qui est vachement intéressant avec
cette idée de chaos et du coup pas
travailler dans le cas où dans la
musique
qui finalement n'est pas si facile que
ça parce que pour longtemps en fait bas
tout ce qu'ils étaient je dirais musique
expérimentale comme ça où on pouvait pas
trop prédire ce qui allait arriver la
mesure d'après n'a pas été très aussi a
été gérée marginalisés et 1 c'est
difficile aujourd'hui pour pour beaucoup
d'auditeurs de musique de pouvoir
rentrer dans ce dans cette célébration
du du chaos sonore et de ce genre de de
fétiches là en tout cas mais mais on y
travaille
en tout cas moi je suis je trouve ça
vachement intéressant justement de faire
entrer des concepts comme ça
scientifique dans l'écriture musicale je
trouve que justement là on comparait de
solidification pour moi ça fait partie
de ce genre de deux buts pour moi de
pouvoir voilà travailler dans ce type de
recherches en tout cas comment vous
appréhendez justement ns2 le vivant le
mouvement c'est assez intéressant parce
que c'est ouais c'est genre j'ai
l'impression que en même temps c'est
quelque chose que j'adore mais c'est une
espèce de voile à 2 de lutte constante
de vouloir séduire ce qui nous séduit je
dirais genre il ya ce truc devoir
maîtriser un peu le mouvement ça passe
par pas mal de workshops pas mal de
recherches et je travaille en binôme
avec avec mon partenaire s'appelle
dimitri avec lequel on a on a fondé un
espèce de groupe de recherche appelle
eito ce qui est vraiment basée sur le
mouvement 1 qui est à la base des sens
de plusieurs disciplines comme le butô
le système a qu'un art martial russe
la méditation latence aussi et tous les
comploteurs saillens et on a essayé de
trouver une façon de pouvoir trouver le
voilà qui était le le le
le point commun entre toutes ces
disciplines et en fait on s'est rendu
compte que le mouvement et quel point
commun entre toutes ces disciplines que
ça soit computer saion savait que les
différents mouvements algorithmes parce
que pour moi je vois les algues comme
aussi un mouvement en fait que ça soit
la danse que ça soit les sports de
combat ça soit
il ya plein de choses qui sont liées
vraiment attraction répulsion ce genre
de choses qu'on peut retrouver dans
différents domaines en fait et ça
c'était ça a été pour moi la façon dont
je me suis constitué cette espèce de
palettes de recherche et aujourd'hui
elle a injecté le mouvement dans
n'importe quoi ça devient pas ce mot
voilà un espèce de signature un peu dans
mon travail c'est intéressant ça m'a
fait réagir
ouais complètement et ça me fait penser
à l'as des as des choses que je trouve
fascinante en un fossé pas c'est pas ma
recherche à proprement parler mais c'est
c'est le raisonnement sur les systèmes
un peu probabiliste c'est à dire qu'en
fait c'est des mouvements je suis désolé
j'ai un peu dit vas y et quant à parler
mais c'est on a des systèmes qui peuvent
sembler complètement aléatoire
complètement chaotique et pourtant il ya
des maths qui permettent de dire barre
en moyenne voilà ce que ça va donner
et c'est intéressant et ce qui compte
est ce que je trouve facilement derrière
ça c'est quelle notion de nombre combien
combien de d'événements vont arriver et
finalement plus on a des événements qui
arrivent et plus on va converger vers
des choses et c'est des choses qui
touchent aux mouvements aussi parce que
quelque part la plus on a de mouvement
en plus on a quelques plans ça peut
paraître intuitif mais plus on a de
mouvement pour la défense que de choses
se rencontrent par exemple et le
mouvement peut être un facteur
extrêmement important et c'est des
choses qui sont souvent pas est très
très bien étudié et parce que souvent ça
fait peur parce qu'on perd un peu pied
si l'on n'a pas assez d'information si
on n'a pas assez d'éléments et il ya
quand même des théories derrière qui
sont qui sont là et c'est fascinant donc
ouais ça fait aussi un peu écho à des
réflexions que que j'aimerais bien
pousser voix alors quelles sont vos
prochaines collaborations vos prochaines
d'inspiration on a peu parlé de
l'intelligence artificielle mais est ce
qu'elle peut s'introduire dans la
science dans la musique nous ont fait
clairement de ce qu'on peut appeler de
l'intelligence artificielle le fait
d'avoir défini l'espace et de pouvoir
décider dans cet espace est ce qu'on
appelle un peu l'intelligence
artificielle c'est pas on n'est pas
vraiment de l'optimisation à proprement
parler mais on est déjà dans une
modélisation et on va laisser
l'ordinateur décider pour nous
une fois que le problème est très bien
poser c'est ça qui je trouve intéressant
c'est qu'on va pas dire quoi faire on va
poser le problème suffisamment bien pour
que ondes et des outils qui nous donne
des solutions qui soient à peu près
optimale et donc dans ce sens là les
collaborations qu'on cherche à faire ça
serait d'utiliser cette ces différents
outils pour résumer le vivant et voir
comment se vivent en résumé peut avoir
un impact dans la compréhension de
choses qui nous qui nous dépasse quoi
c'est à dire enfin il ya deux ans je
crois il y avait joué de rené qui
étaient sur cette scène qui parlait du
du macroscope c'est essayer de voir un
truc qui le plus grand que nous et je
pense qu'il ya les soutiens scop c'est
quoi un microscope on comprend et en
fait macroscope s'est regardé un peu au
dessus et d'un système qui est plus qui
nous englobe même à peu près qui est
plus large que nous et les l'enjeu c'est
toujours resté sur des aspects de la
molécule à l'écosystème comment quelques
molécules qui sont encore une fois des
atomes qui se fabriquent les uns les
autres peuvent avoir des conséquences
sur des sur des macros système donc que
ça peut être un individu si j'ai une
mutation je suis malade
c'est une mutation j'ai un virus qui
devient méchant par exemple si vous ça
vous parle s'il y en a certains gènes
qui sont éventuellement moins bien
sélectionner peut-être qu'on arrivera
moins bien respirer parce qu'il
contribue à la production d'oxygène dans
l'océan mondial
donc c'est connecter ces échelles c'est
ça qui me passionne les lits ap le coût
pourrait à mon sens enfin liées au sens
large aider à comprendre ça donc c'est
une science qui va faire du macroscope
qui va nous permettre d'appréhender des
choses qui ne dépasserait si on avait
simplement nos propres mains et notre
notre tableau et notre crayon
voilà je veux pas monopoliser la parole
parce que tu veux dire ouais c'était de
macroscope ben moi je travaille depuis
je travaille beaucoup et les clients
nous appellent ça une machine learning
cécile à une chose en fait mais c'est
dans la musique le machine en ligne
c'est intéressant parce que ça nous
permet de pouvoir
mais ça c'est une conversation qu'il a
eue la dernière fois sur l'idée du
cantique temps dans les dents dans les
recherches et dans la création voilà la
machine learning ça permet de pouvoir
multiplier des propositions qu'on va
donner à la machine en fait c'est dire
que le cépage les fans mélodie est en
fait va pouvoir me faire une infinité de
mélodies basés sur l'adn de mélodies
mais ça je trouve ça intéressant ça pas
dire que la machine fait le travail à
notre place
mais ça je dirais que ça ça ça ouvre une
palette en ça nous donne du temps et de
l'inspiration n'aurait pas forcément
trouvé comme ça ça permet d'ouvrir jeudi
plusieurs chambres et après elle est
sélectionnée dans les champs ce qui nous
intéresse et c'est une je trouve que
c'est une boutique est intéressant aussi
je pense ou faire développer des
nouveaux systèmes d'écriture je viens de
finir un projet qui s'appelle pelé
kandinsky
justement on a utilisé le mali le
machine learning pour pouvoir faire
apparaître la théorie de candice qui sur
les tableaux en fait sur sa sont ainsi
des saisies ce genre de choses et ce qui
était assez drôle c'est que ça nous a
permis de faire des maths chef par
rapport aux sons quand est ce qu'ils
écoutent et de l'époque avec des choses
plus contemporaines que j'ai composé mon
ami antoine bertin et pouvoir justement
faire un espèce de de mix de tout ça et
avoir le produit le fruit de kandinsky
antoine bertin et moi-même en fait et je
trouve ça vachement intéressant comment
ça peut au la tendance un peu comment ça
peut développer des nouveaux systèmes
créatif et révéler des choses qui
étaient moins évidentes avant dans l'un
de nos pratiques en fait et si je peux
lui poser une question est pour toi le
mash up c'est c'est incertain où tu le
sais déjà à l'avant ce que tu veux
obtenir c'est un truc une amie j'ai un
truc que j'ai appris avec lui ce qui
était computer celle ci tu fallait
accepter de laisser 50% à la machine
peut être voire plus dans les recherches
sur que arrivé avec une idée reçue et
vouloir absolument un résultat pour moi
à la limite je préfère le faire moi même
en fait je ne voudrais pas une machine
de le faire ce qui m'intéresse avec la
machine c'est justement de donner le
choix à l'imprévu peut faire surprendre
dire là sur chaque mois dans la danse
qu'il compte utiliser des machines qui
n'existe pas pour faire du calcul
j'utilise pour faire du dérèglement en
fait
et peut-être qu'à la base je vais partir
du calcul des personnes quelque chose
que je connais on va parler on va
essayer de vulgariser un peu le truc
pour être un peu plus contre et pour les
gens mais voilà je vais je vais vouloir
faire un rythme techno qui est du 4 4
et si je trouve sa taille qu'une machine
ce que je veux savoir pas du 4 4 je veux
qu'elle soit quelque chose de beaucoup
plus décalé donc qui est un espèce de
décalage de temps qui est une espèce de
plasticité dans ma rythmique et ça ça me
sert à çà d'utiliser une machine en fait
et après trouver des relations entre un
kit une ce nerf une mélodie trouvé voilà
d'essayer de faire du brouillard en fait
un nuage de points en fait moi c'est
pour ça que j'utilise les machines en
fait c est quelque chose qui soit
finalement le plus organique possible
alors c'est bizarre parce que on traque
des ordinateurs où finalement il ya
quelque chose de très binaire mais en
vrai ce qui est marrant c'est que quand
je veux comme tu disais tout à l'heure
c'est qu'on arrive à trouver des espèces
de différents types d'algues ory qui
fait quand ils se parlent entre eux en
fait on a vraiment l'impression d'avoir
quelque chose de moi quand je me
l'imaginé en somme je me le visualise en
fait quand je disais à l'ispo deux ans
dont le son que je fais j'ai
l'impression de voir des espèces de
molécules mikros ville
enfin quelque chose qui est très bruyant
d'information et voilà c'est comme ça
que je travaille en fait avec les
machines à bout c'était esthétique que
je recherche à chaque fois
moi si j'avais vendu à ta question si si
si c'est vrai ce qui est drôle
complètement esseulé marrant c'est que
nous on fait la prochain vers c'était a
comparé de nuages de points qui sont on
va dire bordélique et on va essayer de
comprendre quelque chose derrière et on
n'utilise quasiment des méthodes qui
s'apparenterait à peu près aussi à dia
et on essaye de tirer du sens un truc
ultra rigoriste et on a l'impression que
les artistes finalement fond la verse et
c'est pour ça que ça pourrait être
intéressant de 2,2 d'arriver à mieux
interagir entre scientifiques et et
sciences bas et artistes et sciences
pardon parce que quelque part si on fait
une boucle à chaque fois autour de
boucle enfin on gagne quelque chose quoi
ça peut être carrément ce qu'est ce qui
est drôle c'est que l'a récemment alors
je sais pas si vous êtes familier avec
ce qu'on appelle légal c'est générative
adversaire network
c'est une sorte d'intelligence
artificielle en fait qui va
dans tout ce qui est visuel en fait ce
qui s'est brossé une ia qui reconnaît
une image mais pas en tant qu'image
sarko si on voit une maison elle ne voit
pas une maison
elle voit plusieurs pixels et elle voit
des différences de gradient de pixels et
en gros l'idée c'est si on met on lui
donne donc roland traîne et on lui donne
dix mille photos de maisons différentes
elle va reconnaître la structure des
pixels et pour elle c'est vraiment un
sens donc en gros on va pouvoir générer
en fait des design de maisons ont jamais
vraiment existé mais inspirée de ce qu'a
l'a eu dans sa banque est en phase qui
est marrant c'est que quand on commence
à donner à l'ia des éléments qu'il faut
pas des maisons et que elle elle dit pas
moi je connais les maisons et en fait on
lui donne pas des voitures des pommes et
des fruits et dans ça devient
franchement intéressant en fait parce
que là on commence à arriver à des
design qui sont super cool parce que on
arrive à des espèce d'abstraction en
fait et je trouve assez marrant avec les
d'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
c'est bien d'essayer de là à quai en
fête et c'est lui donner justement
d'autres nourritures de l'intoxiquer
avec d'autres choses parce que là on
peut trouver des nouvelles choses qu'on
n'aurait jamais vraiment imaginer de
façon certaine
ce qui est marrant c'est que c'est une
grosse grosse recherche en ya c'est que
maintenant on fait des outils de machine
learning et lé chercheur maintenant
qu'ils cherchent à comprendre cette
boîte noire et c'est un peu ce que tu
racontes quoi c'est que je notamment la
traduction des langues il s'avère que
quand on fait les traductions de langue
c'est on s'attendrait à ce que vouloir
traduire du français a dû chinois par
exemple on passerait à chaque fois par
l'onglet parce que français et anglais
ça marche entre les chinois ça marche en
fait il semblerait que les algues au de
dia ont inventé une langue qui n'existe
pas qui permet de passer plus facilement
d'une langue à l'autre et il ya des gens
qui sont en train d'étudier cette langue
qui n'existe nulle part mais qui est le
résultat d'un processus d'optimisation
pc ouais c'est facile on va passer
maintenant aux questions des internautes
alors on va regarder j'imagine qu'elles
sont nombreuses puisque tout à l'heure
il était on a tendance à penser que les
machines sont plus prévisibles et donc
fiable plus fiables que les êtres
vivants quel est votre avis là-dessus
moi j'ai pas d'avis sur les machines
j'ai plus des avis sur les manières dont
on va me d'élise et les choses avec les
machines donc a priori une fois qu'on a
qu'on concret un outil informatique où
il ya des gens qui sont là pour le
certifier
donc on est capable de savoir à peu près
la famille de la fiabilité le premier la
première des choses qu'on cherche à
faire c'est c'est quantifier sa
fiabilité
après les machines en tant que tel c'est
vrai que pour nous ce fut pour moi
informaticiens c'est un support
informatique ce n'est pas la science de
l'ordinateur c'est c'est la science de
la traction qu'on va utiliser dans les
ordinateurs donc après ça c'est les
électroniciens qui doivent qui pourrait
parler de la machine à proprement parler
et à mon avis les artistes mettre les
machines plus à mal que nous quoi mais
vous était calé à vis de les dire c'est
que j'avais il ya elle eut point de vue
d'un ingénieur après pourvu d'un artiste
pour moi c'est toujours c'est toujours
la même chose en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'il faut jamais voir les machines
comme comme l'outil finale en fait
derrière une conception humaine en fait
et c'est surtout ça qu'il faut se dire
c'est comment on pense en fait quand on
crée un genre d'outils et quelle est la
finalité de de cet outil et et après
c'est enfin excusez moi je suis me perds
un peu mais ce que je vais essayer de
dire c'est que l'idée de créer ces
nouveaux outils
il ya un certain danger en fait et après
dans l'inconscience du bois les machines
vont nous remplacer genre de changement
je pense pas que les machines vont nous
remplacer
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui créent
des machines en voulant remplacer
l'homme c'est pas la même chose mais en
vrai les machines d'elle-même en fait à
son outil ultra performant quand je veux
dire elles sont elles sont optimums mais
ça dépend comme on les utilise en fait
et ça qui peut crier de l'erreur merci
on a c'est là où se placent notre ego en
fait par rapport à la machine ça soit
celui qui litige ou celui qu'il reçoit
et c'est pour moi c'est juste ça le
problème en fait c'est big bro c'est pas
les machines
la machine est au service de l'homme
non à votre avis y at il plus d'imprévu
dans la roue dans la recherche
moi je savais pas dit que je suis pas
artiste alors je ne sais pas mais après
je puisse qu'on a discuté je pense qu'il
ya une recherche qui est pas forcément
la même
dans un cas je pense qu'on va plutôt
avoir tendance à rechercher cet imprévu
donc peut-être qu'on a beaucoup plus
dans l'art et dans la recherche on le
subit mais inversement s'il n'était pas
là on ferait pas de recherche non plus
j'ai envie de dire la fin je sais pas
mon avis je baisse de 10,6 était
d'accord ou pas mais peut-être que dans
l'art c'est le cas c'est le coeur et
alors que nous c'est un peu le sait la
sortie le l'imprévu c'est la sortie
dollar alors que nous l'imprévu c'est
peut-être le début des choses donc de la
quantifier s'il y en a plus dans l'ain
ou dans l'autre dans l'idéal ça devrait
le plus coureuse
c'est marrant parce qu'en fait il ya ça
dépend où on situ l'imprévu parce que
des choses qui vont sont déjà arrivés
ainsi pendant que je fais un set en live
et il ya une machine qui me lâcher voilà
qu'est ce que je fais c'est ça pour moi
lalala prévu et donc du coup il y en a
souvent des imprévus mois à chaque fois
sur sept j'ai plus peur de me dire est
ce qui est une machine qui va me lâcher
il veut être en galère que que et que
que me dirai ce que j'ai fait un bon set
en fait donc finalement à chaque fois il
ya toujours cette notion là et je pense
qu'elle est c'est jamais par rapport à
la science ou l'imprévu pour cbi est
souvent bienvenue parce que ça permet
d'avancer
voir les plus loin donc c'est surtout le
danger est une chose que dans le temps
là en fait quand on regarde dans un
système plus de production on essaie de
de faire en sorte qu'ils le moins
d'imprévus possible en tout cas dans
j'irai dans le rendu final de caisse du
9 mai dans la recherche
je pense qu'on est dans le même dans les
deux cas en fait il ya c'est tout le
temps c'est tout le temps riche on a
prévu quoi qu'elle a été justement le
plus gros imprévu de votre carrière ms
je pense que c'est pas forcément en
terme de recherche tant en termes de vie
en fait les imprévus ont été de me
retrouver par exemple dans après une
séparation amoureuse me retrouver à
faire un projet en alaska par exemple si
tu es complètement imprévue et ça m'a
emmené sur des nouvelles des nouvelles
contrées artistique ça c'est des
imprévus incroyable mais c'est place à
des imprévus qui sont plus sereins sur
un sketch de vie en fait n'est pas sur
un domaine de recherche ou sur une un
truc très spécifique de comment je fais
de la musique c'est voie la plus
personnelle et vous personnellement wes
argent un peu cédé des choses
personnelles
après si je transpose à un peu sur la
science il ya un imprévu qui me nourrit
un jour c'est que on était avec un
collègue cela choque pas en train de
disserter sur un tableau et on avait
l'impression qu'on travaille sur la même
chose mais en fait on en fait non on se
comprenait pas et il nous a fallu
quasiment une heure pour pour justement
à force d'arguments de dire de moi c'est
moi je sais ça mais non tu peux pas dire
ça pour qu'on se rende compte qu'on
parlait pas de la même chose mais
finalement ça sort en boîte est
tellement bien qu'on a réussi à faire un
gros morceau mais on est en travaillant
chacun de notre côté et en fait ce qui
nous a manqué c'est d'être capable de
nous comprendre donc l'imprévu c'est
aussi ça c'est le sait de l'humanité
c'est être capable de parler avec les
gens et c'est beaucoup plus facile
quelque part de créer ce genre d'imprévu
pas avec des avec des copains enfin je
veux dire on fait beaucoup plus de
recherches avec les gens avec lesquels
on sent proche passé parce qu'on est
prêt à s'exposer aussi on est prêt à
dire non mais là je comprends pas et ça
c'est un peu une histoire d'ego 6 1
c'est que si on veut dire mais les
risques au tf1 s'est hissée
salut j'ai à dire c'est aussi le ce truc
du chaos le chaos dans la communication
aux siens et ça ce qui fait que ça nous
fait des trucs aussi son ca intéressant
quand on se retrouve à parler du cas où
ce soir en fait que pensez-vous de la
proprioception
allez je connais pas ses mots allant des
primeurs une définition